İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 22 Ocak 2025 Çarşamba günü 57. ders günümüz ve saat 19.30 dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
İşte kaldığımız yer arkadaşlar burasıydı. Şöyle bir bakalım.
Evet. Yok burası değildi. Bir dakika. Dosya bölen bir program yazmıştık. Onu bulmaya çalışayım. Evet.
Şöyle önce dersin sonu biraz aceleye geldi. Programımızı bir kez daha izleyelim. Üstünden geçelim.
Programımız komut satırından şu şekilde çalıştırılacak idi.
Programın ismi diyelim ki egzenin ismi böldoz, boldoz. İkinci komut satırı argümanı bölünecek dosyanın ismi. Üçüncü komut satırı argümanı kaç byte'lık parçalar olacak.
Yani bölünecek dosyalar. Bölünme sonucu elde edilecek dosyalar kaç byte olacak.
Şöyle bir algoritmayı izledik. Bu dosyayı okuma amaçlı ve geçen derste yaptığımız uyarıyı hatırlayalım.
Binary modda açtık.
Ve arkadaşlar bölünmüş dosyaların bölme sonucu elde edebilecek dosyaları yazma amaçlı açıyoruz.
Yine binary modda.
Teker teker dosyaları açıyoruz.
Ona bu kadar byte yazdıktan sonra dosyayı kapatıp diğer parçayı taşıyacak yeni dosyayı açıyoruz.
Böylece dosya diyelim ki bin byte'lık parçalara bölünüyor.
Şöyle kodumuzun üstünden geçelim. Geçen dersin sonunda yazmıştık.
Program komut satırından üç komut satırı argümanıyla çalıştırılacağı için
ArcC'nin değerinin üç olup olmadığını sınıyorum.
Eğer üç değilse yanlış sayıda komut satırı argümanıyla çalıştırıldığı için
bir hata mesajı verip programı sonlandırıyorum.
Hata mesajı derken programın nasıl kullanılacağını gösteren bir açıklamayla
ki bu geleneksel yaklaşım biliyorsunuz.
Komut satırından çalıştırılacak programlar için.
Evet şöyle göstergemizi de açalım.
Takip etmeye çalışın.
24. satırdan başlayarak if stream sınıfı türünden bir nesneyi oluşturdum
ve birinci komut satırı argümanı, bir indeksi komut satırı argümanında
ismi olan dosyayı böylece okuma amaçlı açtım.
iOS'un in'i default olarak geliyordu ama default adış modu text moduydu.
O yüzden iOS binary flag'ini, bayrağını eklemek zorundayım.
Dosya açılamadıysa stream fail durumuna düşecek.
Yine geçen dersi hatırlayalım.
Burada aslında bunu kontrol etmenin en az 4-5 yolu var.
Operatör değil fonksiyonu, fail isimli fonksiyon, good fonksiyonu.
Arkadaşlar tabi onun değdini almam gerekiyor geri dönüş değerinin ve hatta yine geçen
derste konuştuğumuz üzere is open fonksiyonu.
Arkadaşlar şu byte değeri yazı olarak geldiği için standart kütüphanenin C kütüphanesinden
gelen stud atui fonksiyonunu çağırarak atui'yi hatırlayalım.
Atui şöyle bir fonksiyon.
Tabi bu dönüşümü yapacak başka fonksiyonlar da var ama konumuz bu değil.
Atui şöyle bir fonksiyon değil mi?
Int atui const char yıldız.
Yine aynı konuda atu f, atu l, atu ll gibi arkadaşlar fonksiyonlar var.
Yani farklı türler için C'de function overloading olmadığı için farklı isimlendirilmiş fonksiyonlar var.
Bu değere chunk dedim.
İşte bir dosyaya chunk tane byte yazdığımda o dosyayı kapatıp yeni dosyayı açacağım.
Dosya isimlerinin oluşturulması için yine geçen derslerden birinde öğrendiğimiz
e-stream başlık dosyasındaki belleğe yazma amaçlı kullanılacak o string stream sınıfını kullandım ki birçok örnek yaptık.
Arkadaşlar tabi burada başka bir alternatif C++20 standardı destekleniyorsa
doğrudan stud format kütüphanesine stud format fonksiyonunu çağırmak.
Dosya isimleri şu şekilde olacaktı.
Parça 001 par artan sırada gidiyor.
İşte onu o formatlı yazı şeklinde oluşturmak için yazma alanı genişliğinden arta kalan kısma
sıfırla doldurulmasını istedim.
Sonra arkadaşlar burası önemli yazma amaçlı dosyaları kontrol etmek için bu sefer de off-stream sınıfı türünden bir nesneyi default construct ettim ki bu ne demek?
Şu anda bir dosyaya dosyayla ilişkilendirilmemiş demek.
Yani is open fonksiyonunu çağırsak false değer dönecek.
Buradaki char değişkeni tanımlama nedeni ise dosyadan byte byte okuma yapacak olmam ki bunu yapan
C'deki fgc fonksiyonunun burada karşılığı diyebileceğimiz iki tane get overloadu var.
Burada çağırdığım get overloadu bunların hepsini geçen derste konuştuk parametresi char ref olan yani her çağrıda dosya konum göstericisi olan offset'teki byte oku benim gönderdiğim referans semantiliyle gönderdiğim değişkeni set ediyor.
Peki ne zaman bu döngüden çıkacak?
Stream fail olduğunda çünkü bu fonksiyonlar get fonksiyonları yine yıldız diz stardis döndürüyor.
Dolayısıyla lojik bağlamda operatör bool fonksiyonu çağrılıyor ve stream fail olduğunda yani başka bir nedenle herhangi bir hata oluşmazsa
e-off durumuna geçtiğinde bu döngüden çıkacak.
Şimdi burası çok önemli.
Döngünün her durumda bizim bir dosyaya yazabilmemiz için yazma amaçlı dosyalardan birinin açık olduğundan emin olmamız gerekiyor.
Açıksa daha chunk kadar byte yazmamışım demektir.
Açık değilse chunk kadar byte yazmış ve dosyayı kapatmışım demektir.
Dolayısıyla isOpen fonksiyonu false değer dönerse ya hiç dosyayınız açılmamış ya da yazma amaçlı son açılan dosya kapatılmış.
Yani o fs offstream nesnesine bağlanmış yazma amaçlı bir dosya yok.
Dosyanın ismini oluşturmak için belleğe yazma işlevinden faydalandım.
İşte buradaki o ss hatırlayın o string stream türünden nesne yukarıda 34. satırda tanımlanan set ve manipülatörünü kullanarak
3 karakterlik alana file count artı 1 değerini yazmasını istedim ki file count 0 olduğu için
burada ilk dosyaya açışta dosyanın ismi parça 001.par olacak.
sınıfın Open fonksiyonuyla birinci parametresine dosyanın ismi olarak o string stream nesnesini str fonksiyonundan aldığım arkadaşlar string'i verdim.
İkinci parametresine de yine Binary modda açılması için iOS Binary flag'ini ekledim.
Burada da iOS alt flag'i default olarak geliyordu.
Arkadaşlar bu arada küçük bir not.
Şimdi eğer çalıştığınız işte aynı zamanda eski C++'da kullanılıyorsa
ya da sadece legacy kodlarla uğraşıyorsanız eski C++ kullanılıyorsa
eski C++'ın standart kütüphanesinde maalesef şöyle bir özellik vardı.
Bazı fonksiyonların örneğin bu stream sınıflarının konstruktörü ya da Open fonksiyonu gibi
bunlar yazıları C usulü c string parametreyle istiyordu.
Dolayısıyla elimizde stu string nesnesi varken string nesnesini gönderemiyordum.
Çünkü biliyorsunuz stu string'ten c string'e örtülü dönüşüm yok.
Ama hatırlayın string sınıfının c str fonksiyonunu çağırıyordum.
Bunu söylememin bir nedeni de elinizde bir string nesnesi var ise eski kodlarda
burada belki şöyle bir ifadenin bulunduğunu göreceksiniz ama günümüzde gerekli değil.
Çünkü ne oldu?
Sonra sadece c string overloadu olan bu fonksiyonlara bir de stu string overloadu eklendi.
Yani şimdi hem stream sınıflarının, file stream sınıflarının konstruktörü hem de Open fonksiyonları
c string'i de kabul ediyor, stu string'i de kabul ediyor.
Dosya oluşturulamamışsa olağan dışı bir neden olmadıkça dosyanın oluşturulmaması ihtimali yok ama
yine de kontrol etmekte fayda var.
Bir hata mesajı hata akımına yazdırdım ve dosyanın oluşturulamadığını açıklayan bir yazı oldu.
Bu tür arkadaşlar loglamalar şüphesiz debug sürecinde de bir fayda sağlıyor.
Ve her dosya için, oluşturulmuş her dosya için file count değişkeninin değerini bir arttırdım.
Bunu dosyaya yazmak için o stream sınıfının put fonksiyonunu çağırdım.
Nasıl c'de put car fonksiyonu varsa, burada da o stream sınıfının put fonksiyonu
formatsız bir byte yazan, bir karakter yazan streame fonksiyon.
Ve sonra byte count değişkeninin değerini de arttırdım.
Şimdi byte count burada toplam yazılacak byte sayısını tuttuğu için
dosyanın chunk kadar byte'ı alıp almadığını kontrol etmek için
her defasında byte count'u sıfırlamak yerine
mod operatöründen faydalandım.
Mod operatörünün güzel kullanımlarından biri bu tür durumlarda.
Nedense programcıların aklına mod operatörünü kullanmak gelmiyor.
Mesela bu kodu şöyle yazıyorlar.
Her defasında chunk kadar byte yazıldığında byte count'u tekrar sıfırlıyorlar.
Bu durumda toplam byte miktarına da ihtiyaç duydukları için ayrı bir
kümülatif toplam tutan bir değişken daha tanımlıyorlar.
Ama burada mod operatörü aslında kodu daha basit, daha pratik hale getiriyor.
Yine 52. satıra bakınız.
Eğer byte count'ın chunk'a bölümünden kalan sıfırsa
demek ki dosyaya chunk kadar byte yazılmış demektir.
sınıfın close fonksiyonuyla dosyayı kapatıyorum.
Ve o string stream nesnesinin o yazıyı tuttuğu bellek alanında
oradaki yazıyı resetlemek için diyelim ya da onu borç yazı haline getirmek için
bu sefer str fonksiyonunun set parametrelisini çağırıyorum.
Arkadaşlar burada bakka bir olanakçı olabilirdi.
Bakınız o string stream nesnesinin her defasında arkadaşlar şu str fonksiyonunu çağırmak yerine
o string stream nesnesini döngünün gövdesinde otomatik ömürlü yerel bir değişken yapardım.
Ve böylece otomatik ömürlü yerel bir değişken yaratıldığında
döngünün ana bloğunun sonuna geldiğinde destroy olurdu.
Böylece bir sonraki turda yeni nesne hayata gelirdi.
Ama o minimalde olsa ilave bir maliyet ekleyecekti.
Arkadaşlar burada tabii ki en son dosyanın yine arkadaşlar file nesnelerinin destraktör'ı çağrıldığında
destraktör dosya açıksa onu kapatıyor.
Bu stream nesneleri biliyorsunuz file stream nesneleri rayi gidiyor bunu kullanıyor.
gününün çıkışında bir de en azından doğru çalışıp çalışmadığını test etmek için
efendim byte count byte'lık 22400 byte'lık örnek falanca dosyası biner byte'lık
24 dosyaya bölündü böyle bir yazı çıkacak.
Şimdi yine clean alalım tekrar derliyorum.
Benim yaptığım ayarlarla egze dosya burada oluşuyor ve ismi a.egze olarak oluşturuluyor.
Hatta şimdi bakın dir yıldız.egze işte a.egze ama ben bunun ismini değiştireyim.
rename a.egze dos böl.egze evet dos bölü de geldi dir yıldız.egze görüyorsunuz şu 30208 byte.
Arkadaşlar şimdi doğru çalışıp çalışmadığını test etmek için daha önce benim C kursunda yazdığım
bu programlardan bir tanesinin egze'sini kullanacağım.
Bakınız burada negün.egze isimli bir negün şöyle negün.egze isimli bir program var.
Bakalım nasıl çalıştırılıyormuş.
Kullanım ne gün gün ay yıl mesela 15.02.1987 ama son komut satırı argümanı da o günden kaç gün sonrası olduğu.
Yani aslında bu basit utility programı bir C'de yazmıştık C kursunda.
O kursa katılan arkadaşlardan varsa belki hatırlayacaklar.
bir tarihten en gün sonrasının hangi tarih olduğunu buluyor.
O zaman önce bu ne günü bir gösterelim.
Ne gün?
Örneğin arkadaşlar 22 Ocak 2025 ve 1387 gün sonrası.
Bakın ekran çıktısına 22 Ocak 2025 çarşamba 1387 gün sonrası 9 Kasım 2028 Perşembe.
Peki bunu neden yaptım?
Eğer programımızda bir hata yoksa dosyaları böldükten sonra birlikte bir de dosyaları birleştirecek program yazacağız ya.
O programla dosyaları birleştirdiğimizde o elde edeceğimiz dosya işte aynı egze dosyaya eş fakat ismi farklı bir dosya olacak.
Yani onu da bu şekilde çalıştırdığımızda aynı şekilde çalışması gerekiyor.
O zaman arkadaşlar çalıştıralım dos böl ne gün nokta egze bakın kaç byte olduğuna bakın 11.264 byte 500 byte'lık parçalara böleyim.
Arkadaşlar 11 tane 500 özür dilerim 22 tane 500 11.000 yapar.
Bir de son dosyanın uzunluğunun 264 byte olması gerekir öyle değil mi?
Yani toplamda 23 tane dosya oluşması gerekir.
Bakalım diyor ki 11.264 byte'lık ne gün egze dosyası 500 byte'lık 23 dosyaya bölündü.
Peki gerçekten bizim isim formatımıza uygun dosyalar oluştu mu?
Bir yıldız nokta par evet evet bakın parça 001 pardan parça 022 par dahil 500 byte ama parça 023 par 264 byte.
Yani bölme işlemi başarıyla gerçekleştirildi.
Şimdi birleştirme programını yazacağız birlikte ama hemen şimdi şunu söyleyelim birleştirme programı ne yapacak?
Bu par uzantılı dosyaları bu sırayla birleştirerek yeni bir dosya elde edecek.
İşte bu programın komut satırından arkadaşlar silelim hepsini komut satırından şöyle çalıştırılmasını istiyorum.
Diyelim ki dos bir dosya birleştir.
İsmi efendim neco nokta egze.
dos bir programı neco nokta egze'yi oluşturacak ama neco nokta egze'yi oluştururken uzantısı par olan dosyaları birleştirerek oluşturacak.
Aslında buradaki algoritma daha da basit.
Neden?
Arkadaşlar bizim dosya formatımız şöyle değil miydi?
Parça 001 par ve en son parça 023 par.
O zaman yazma amaçlı bir dosya oluşturacağız.
Buraya dikkat.
Okuma amaçlı dosyalar bu sefer sırasıyla parça 001'i açacak.
Yazma amaçlı dosyaya hepsini yazacak.
Sonra parça 002'yi açacak.
Aynı işlemi tekrar edecek.
Ama kaç tane dosya olduğunu bilmediğimiz için başka bir hata olmadığı sürece örneğin parça 023 par açılacak.
Ama parça 024 parı açma girişiminde bulunduğumuzda açma işlemi başarısız olacak.
Bunu başka bir hata söz konusu değilse neye yoracağız?
Demek ki dosyaların hepsini bitirmişiz.
Yalnız burada bir şeye daha dikkat etmek gerekiyor.
Arkadaşlar şimdi bu işlemden sonra biz birleştirdikten sonra uzantısı par olan dosyaları o direktörü de tutarsak o zaman program tekrar çalıştırıldığında bölme programı ortalık karışır.
Çünkü birleştirme programı daha önceki çalıştırmadan gelen parları da birleştirmeye çalışır.
O yüzden birleştirme işlemini gerçekleştirdikten sonra burada ben par uzantılı dosyaları sileceğim.
Hemen o zaman burada bir soru soralım C programcılarına.
C'de dosya silen ve dosya ismi değiştiren fonksiyonları hatırlıyor musunuz?
Studiokit mahallesinde iki tane basit fonksiyon.
Ki bu fonksiyonları C++ programlarında da çağırabiliriz.
Hatırlayan var mı?
Dosya silen standart C fonksiyonu cevap hatırlayan yok sanırım.
İsmi remove olan fonksiyon arkadaşlar geri dönüş değeri başarı int.
Başarı int derken neyi kastediyorum?
Sıfır dönerse dosya silinmiş demektir.
Nazira dönerse dosya silinmemiş demektir.
Fonksiyonun prototipi şöyle int remove const char yıldız parneyin.
Yani gestring olarak dosyanın ismini istiyor.
O dosyayı siliyor.
Yalnız işletim sistemlerinin hemen hepsinde ama bu tabii işletim sistemine bağlı dosyanın silinebilmesi için dosyanın kapalı olması koşulu çoğunlukla var.
Ama bu işletim sistemine bağlı.
Fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri başarı bilgisi sıfır dönerse başarılı.
Nazira dönerse başarısız.
Her ne kadar burada dosya ismini değiştirmekle ilgili rename fonksiyonunu çağırmayacaksak da Abdülkadir Akar bravo rename de şöyle.
Birinci parametre dosyanın var olan ismi.
İkinci parametre ismi değişince yeni isim yani onun yerine hangi ismi alacak?
Nosyar yıldız arkadaşlar nirney.
Yine geri dönüş değeri başarı int başarılı olursa yani dosyanın ismi değiştirilmişse sıfır değeri dönecek.
Değiştirilmemişse naziro dönecek.
Bu açıklamalardan sonra artık kodumuzu yazmaya başlayabiliriz.
Yine her zaman olduğu gibi ben bir hata yaparsam siz zamanda uyarın ki sonra hatayı bulmak için zaman kaybetmeyelim.
Arkadaşlar yine komut satırından çalıştıracağım.
Int, argc, char, yıldız yıldız, argv.
Tabi artık bunlar çok temel konular şöyle de yazabilirdim derleyici açısından bir anlam farkı yok.
Burada komut satırından bu şekilde çalıştırılacağı için program argc'nin 2 olması gerekir.
if argc eşit değilse 2.
Arkadaşlar oyostream başlık dosyasını dahil ederim.
Çünkü CRR nesnesini kullanacağım.
Arkadaşlar bu arada ben genelde kaynak dosyalarda şöyle yapıyorum.
Size de tavsiye ederim.
Olağan dışı bir neden yoksa başlık dosyalarının include sırası aslında önemli değil.
Önemli olan o bildirimlerin görülmesi.
Ama birçok programcı benim yaptığım gibi o isimlerin, identifierların kaynak kodda yukarıdan aşağıya görülme sırasıyla başlık dosyalarını include ediyor.
Mesela bakın buraya kadar, buraya kadar hiçbir standart kütüphaneden ya da 3. parti bir kütüphaneden gelecek hiçbir identifier'ı kullanmadım.
Ama şimdi CRR'yi kullandığım için ata halkımı arkadaşlar oyostream'i include ettim.
Deniz Akkuş, oyostream dosya yoksa açar.
Offstream, sanırım onu evet bravo.
Offstream dosya yoksa açar demiştik.
Doğru.
Arkadaşlar folder yoksa da folder oluşturur mu?
Şimdi folder yoksa folder oluşturması yine işletim sistemiyle ilgili.
Normal olarak arkadaşlar burada yol verebiliyorsunuz.
Yani Rupet altında efendim Necati direktörüsünün folder'ının içinde efendim mektuplar folder'ının içinde bu dosya oluşturulsun diyebiliyorsunuz.
Ama folder'ın oluşturulup oluşturulmaması büyük ölçüde işletim sistemine bağlı.
CRR'e arkadaşlar zaten en başta da söyledim bakınız aslında bu dosya işlemleri yani espri olsun diye söylüyorum hikaye.
Yani bu bir sadece wrapper layer aslında.
Aslında burada dosyalarla ilgili yaptığımız bütün işlemleri yapan kim?
İşletim sisteminin sistem fonksiyonları, dosya işlemleri arkadaşlar bravo çağrı, operating sistem API'ları diyor çağrı ve kesinlikle.
Aynı şekilde bakın concurrency konusuna geldiğimizde de göreceğiz.
Eğer modern C++'dan önce öyleydi zaten concurrency sınıfları olmasaydı biz multi-thread programlama tarafında işletim sisteminin API'lerini kullanmak durumunda kalacaktık ve eskiden de öyleydi.
Yani örneğin Windows altında koşacaksa Windows'un API'lerini efendim Unix Linux gökenli sistemlerde de P-Thread kütüphanesini kullanıyorduk ki
bu arada tavsiye ederim Kaan Bey'in, Kaan Aslan'ın benim de kuzen oluyor kendisi.
Bu Unix Linux sistem programlama kursunda işte bu Unix Linux sistemleri artık olabilecek en ince detayına kadar bütün özellikleriyle dosya sistemleri, concurrency anlatılıyor.
O yüzden biraz uzun bir kurs 300 saat miydi, 500 saat miydi neydi Allah sabır versin diyelim ama çok faydalı bir kurs gerçekten.
Evet şöyle diyelim kullanım Türkçe yazıyorum kullanım ne şekilde kullanılacağını gösteren bir yazı olsun arkadaşlar ne olacak işte dos bir programın isminin dos bir olduğunu düşünelim efendim filename bu kadar öyle değil mi?
Tamam bir de New Line verelim ve arkadaşlar return bir hata kodu.
Ben şimdi böyle programlarda bunu da söyleyeyim tabii böyle yapmak zorunda değilsin C'de de böyle yapıyordum C kursuna katılan arkadaşlar hatırlayacaklar.
Farklı eğer main fonksiyonunu da sonlandırıyorsam bir hata sonucu farklı nedenlerle sonlandırdığımda farklı return kodları veriyorum ki bunlar işletim sistemi tarafından mesela o shell kısmında belki de kullanılmaya aday olsunlar.
Peki şimdi artık işimize başlayabiliriz dosya işlemleri için upstream başlık dosyasını dahil ettim ve stud upstream türünden arkadaşlar bir nesne oluşturdum.
Bu yeni dosya olacak bu kez dolayısıyla ismi ARGB1'den gelecek bakın şimdi çok iyi görüyoruz bakın şimdiye kadar ki örneklerde biz aslında hep stud string gönderdik değil mi?
Fakat şimdi ben constral yıldız gönderiyorum evet constral yıldız örtülü olarak stud string'e dönüşüyor ama hayır burada öyle bir dönüşüm olmuyor.
Burada aslında arkadaşlar fonksiyonun yani constructor'ın bir overload'u var.
Constructor'ın overload'u belki de gösteriyordur burada arkadaşlar.
Constructor'ın overload'u ne istiyor bizden?
Aynı zamanda bir overload'u stud string demin bu açıklama yapmıştım bir overload'u gest string istiyor.
ARGB1 ve stud IOS binary.
Yine geçen dersimizde out'un örtülü olarak geldiğini default olarak geldiğini söylemiştik ama şüphesiz şöyle yazsaydım stud IOS out bitsel veya anlamsal açıdan bir değişiklik olmayacak.
Ama gerek olmadığı için yazmamayı tercih ediyorum.
Arkadaşlar bu tür programlarda ister dosya okuma amaçlı açılsın ister yazma amaçlı açılsın hiçbir zaman garantisi yok.
Yani okuma amaçlı açıldığında açılamamasının en tipik nedeni dosyanın olmayışı.
Yine geçen dersimizi hatırlayın uzun uzun konuşmuştuk.
Ama yazma amaçlı açıldığında da tipik olarak başarılı olacak ama ne bileyim mesela işletim sistemi tarafında bir hata olabilir.
Evet hemen program başlar başlamaz bu çalışmak zorunda değil.
Bellek eksikliği, bellek alanı yetersizdir.
Önce dosyanın bufferlama sistemi için bir buffer alanı elde edilemeyeceği için de örneğin dosya açılamayabilir.
O yüzden mutlaka bence kontrol edin.
Dosya kontrol edebileceğimizi konuşmuştuk.
Yine burada stosiyere diyelim ki arkadaşlar argv1 dosyası oluşturulamadı.
Tabi debug tarafında da çok fayda sağlıyor değil mi?
Yani şimdi bunları kontrol yapmasak adanın buradan geldiğini de anlayamayacağız.
Değil mi?
Evet return 2.
Süper.
Şimdi yazma amaçlı dosyayı oluşturduk.
Ve yine en azından arkadaşlar iki tane değişkene ihtiyacım var.
Biri en az bir değişkene ihtiyacım var.
Pile count çünkü dosya ismini oluşturacağım.
Pile count değişkenimizin değeri 0 olsun.
Ama bir değişken daha tanımlıyorum.
Int by count çünkü çalıştırırken gerçekten oluşan dosyanın büyüklüğünde bir yazdırmak istiyorum.
Pile count değişkeninin değeri de 0.
Eğer şöyle bir soru varsa Necati 0 değeriyle bir tam sayı değişkeni başlatmak için böyle mi yazıyorsun?
Arkadaşlar tabi ki böyle yazmak zorunda değilim.
Yani bunları artık çok temel.
Şöyle yazabilirim.
Direct initialization.
Copy initialization.
Şöyle yazabilirim.
Direct list initialization.
Ama böyle yazdığımda hadi bir soru da benden eski dersler unutuldu mu?
Bu şekilde ilk değer vermeye.
Listinit değil.
Value initialization deniyordu.
Value initialization kullanılan terim.
Evet.
Peki.
Şimdi algoritmayı anlatmıştım.
Arkadaşlar şöyle yapacağım.
Parça 001 par açıldığında onu yazma amaçlı dosyaya yazacağım.
Ama parça 002 döngünün bir sonraki turunda açmaya çalışacağım.
Açılamazsa o dosyanın olmadığına hükmedeceğim ve döngüden çıkacağım.
Bu tür durumlarda döngüden nereden çıkılacağı baştan belli değilse sonsuz döngü idiomunu kullanmak daha iyi bir teknik kodun okunmasını, yazılmasını kolaylaştırıyor.
Sonsuz döngü idiomunu hepinizin bildiği gibi idiomatik şekilde iki farklı biçimde yazabiliyorum.
Benim normalde tercihim bu ama while true'da da tabii ki bir sorun yok.
Eskiden şöyle şeyler konuşuluyordu.
Şimdi bana çok komik geliyor.
C'nin C++'ın ilk zamanlarında.
İşte efendim while bir yazma, onun yerine for yaz, daha etkili bir kod oluşsun.
Ama günümüzün koşullarında, o zaman da pek doğru değildi ya, günümüzün koşulları da bunlar derleyiciler için son derece komik optimizasyonlar.
Yani bunu düşünmeye bile gerek yok.
Derleyici neler neler yapıyor o optimizasyon modülü.
Arkadaşlar bu sefer o string stream nesnesini, s stream başlık dosyasını dahil ediyorum.
Döngünler turunda, bir yerini de göstermiş olayım, bir öncekini de böyle yazmamıştım.
Döngünler turunda oluşturayım.
O string stream, diyelim ki oss.
Arkadaşlar isimleri birbirine yakın seçmek de iyi bir fikir değil.
Kodlama hatalarının önemli bir kısmı, isimler birbirine yakın seçildiği için bir değişkenin ismi yerine,
yanlışlıkla bir de başka değişkenin ismini yazma biçiminde karşımıza çıkıyor kodlama hatalarının bir kısmı.
Bunda nedeni değişken isimlerinin birbirine yakın seçilmesi.
Mesela x1, x2, x3 gibi.
Ya da burada biri oss, biri ofs.
Allah korusun mesela oss yerine ofs yazsam,
tabii çok durumda sentaks hatası olacak ama bazı durumlarda zaten bu tür hatalar daha seyrek oluşuyor.
oluşuyor ama oluşunca da daha fazla can yakıyor.
Evet.
Alihan Bozkır diyor ki,
out ss diyelim.
Out ss.
Evet.
SS bizim Eskişehir Spor'un kısaltması.
Evet, ben SS deyince hep Eskişehir Spor akıma geliyor.
Gerçi şu anda üçüncü ligden ikinci ligye çıkmaya çalışıyor ama bir zamanlar
Türkiye Ligi'nin fırtınalar esteren futbol takımıydı.
Evet.
Şimdi yine out ss arkadaşlar bu sefer setfil manipülatörünü kullanıyorum.
Ama setfil manipülatörü parametreli manipülatörü Almanya'da evet ss çok farklı anlama geliyor.
Nazi döneminde değil mi?
Açılımının ne olduğunu hatırlıyor musunuz Yusuf?
Storn oradan geliyor değil mi?
Yok değil.
Şut ştufa.
Şut ştufa'dan geliyor.
Evet.
Peki.
Bir de şey vardı ne Abdailung'tu bu Nazi döneminde?
O da SS polis teşkilatının ismi neydi?
Neyse hatırlamadım.
Bir şey Abdailung'tan geliyordu.
Evet.
Polis teşkilatı Gestapo.
Neyse biz konumuza geri dönelim.
İsim ablamı epeyce göçmüş.
IOMANIP başlık dosyasında dahil ediyorum.
IOMANIP başlık dosyasında parametreli manipülatörler oradaydı.
Ve setfil manipülatörünü arkadaşlar 0 gersin başına dedim.
Şimdi alt SS bellek üstünde önce parça yazılsın.
Sonra arkadaşlar her defasında tekrar ediyorum ben sizi de bıktırıyorum ama işte bu format kütüphanesinin ne kadar büyük bir fayda sağladığını.
SA'yı evet Sturm Abdailung onu demin ikisini birbiriyle karıştırdım dedim ya Sturm Abdailung böyle bir şey de diye o SA değil mi Sturm Abdailung?
Evet.
Parça o zaman bu sefer de yine başka bir parametreli manipülatör.
Stutzet ve 3 karakterlik alana.
FileCount değişkeninin değeri 0 ama bizim ilk oluşturacağımız dosyanın ismi efendim parça 001 para olacak.
Dolayısıyla FileCount plus 1 artı 1 ondan sonra da nokta R.
Oysa stutz format ne yapsaydım doğrudan format fonksiyonuna çağrı yapıp format fonksiyonunun geri dönüş değeri olan stutz string destesini kullanacaktım.
Şimdi burası dosya ismini oluşturduğum kısım artık dosyayı açabilirim stutz ifstream ifs arkadaşlar dosyanın ismi outss.str onu görmüştük ama yine binary modu için stutz ios arkadaşlar binary.
Evet baksı açılamadıysa yine bu sefer hata olarak görmeyeceğim söylemiştim.
Artık başka bir parın olmadığına hükmeteceğim.
O yüzden if değil ifs döngüden çıktım.
Bakın döngüden çıkış noktası burada.
Arkadaşlar ben C kursunda katılan arkadaşlarım bir kısmı programlamayla yeni tanışmış oluyor.
Bir kısmı başka programlama dillerinde belirli bir süre çalıştıktan sonra C öğrenmek istiyorlar.
Onlara hep şunu söylüyorum.
Döngü deyimlerini yazmakta başta programcılar biraz zorluk çekiyor bir döngüyü kurgulamakta.
Çoğunlukla da zorluk çekmelerinin nedeni gerek for döngüsü olsun gerek while döngüsü olsun
döngüden çıkış koşulunu illa döngünün başında yazmak istemeleri.
Bazen döngünün çıkış koşulu döngünün başında çok açık bir şekilde belli ama bazen onu kestirmek o kadar kolay değil ya da mümkün değil.
Mesela burada illa bu koşulu döngünün başına taşısaydım ya mümkün olmayacaktı ya da belki o daha karmaşık hale gelecekti.
Yani sonsuz döngü idiomunun gerçekten fayda sağladığı yerler var.
Ama bazen de şöyle yapıyoruz arkadaşlar.
Sonsuz döngü idiomunu kullanıyoruz.
Ama sonra bakıyoruz ki aslında pekala döngünün başında o kontrol yapılabilir.
Refactoring yapıp koşulu yine döngünün başına alıyoruz.
Gidince hocam şimdi dosyanın açılamama sebebi başka bir sebepse çok güzel nasıl bir önlem almalıyız.
Arkadaşlar dosyanın açılamama sebebi başka ne olabilir?
Mesela nasıl önlem alabiliriz?
Sınıfın bad fonksiyonunu çağırabiliriz.
Yani efendim işletim sistemi tarafından tamir edilemeyecek şekilde bir hata varsa stream bad konumuna geliyordu.
Hocam bu arada ATSS for'un içinde mi olmalı?
Rasul orayı kaçırmış olabilirsiniz.
Bir önceki programda o string stream nesnesini döngünün dışında kullanmıştım.
Şimdi özellikle döngünün içinde kullanıyorum.
Özellikle daha iyi ya da daha kötü anlamında değil.
Böylece yazıyı oluşturduktan sonra tekrar sınıfın STL fonksiyonunu set amaçlı çağırmayacağım.
Yani aslında benim tercihim sizin dediğiniz gibi dışarıda oluşturmakta ama ikinci alternatifi göstermek istedim.
Çünkü zaten birinci alternatifi o bölme tarafında yazmıştık hatırladınız mı?
Evet o açıklamayı yaptım belki kaçırmış olabilirsiniz.
Mesela WinAPI'de read write access gibi parametreler veriyorsunuz.
Arkadaşlar tabii şimdi bakın thread kısmında da böyle bizim standart kütüphanenin verdiği API'ler her zaman ilave bir layer yani bir sarmalama, bir wrapping.
Dolayısıyla işletim sisteminin fonksiyonları her zaman daha ince ayar sağlıyor.
Yani eğer taşınabilerek gibi bir kaygınız yoksa işletim sisteminin sistem fonksiyonlarını kullanmak daha iyi.
Birkaç nedenle daha iyi olabilir.
Nedenlerden biri bazı işlemler için ilave katman, ilave bir maliyet getiriyor olabilir.
Yani diyelim ki ben C++'ın standart kütüphanesi yerine işletim sisteminin fonksiyonunu çağırsam belki daha az maliyetli olacak ki birçok durumda ben böyle olduğunu gözlüyorum.
İkincisi ise işletim sisteminin sistem fonksiyonları her zaman daha ince bir kontrol sağlıyor.
İşte tam da Çağrı Bey'in dediği gibi yani okuma yazma yerleşimleri şunlar bunlar çok fazla kontrol sağlıyor.
Özellikle bu thread tarafında, concurrency tarafında bu çok belirgin.
Yani threadlerle ilgili yapabileceğim bazı şeyleri maalesef C++'ın standart kütüphanesi bana yapma olanağı vermiyor.
O yüzden aslında burada da öyle yapabilirlerdi.
Şöyle bir yol var Çağrı.
Ne yapıyorlar biliyor musunuz?
Bu kontrol sağlık kütüphanesinde bu sarmalayıcı sınıflar, rapper sınıflar ismi Native Handle olan bir fonksiyon veriyorlar.
Eğer siz hem standart kütüphaneyi hem de işletim sisteminin apilerini birlikte kullanmak istiyorsanız standart kütüphaneyle başlıyorsunuz ama işletim sisteminde ince ayar gereken yerde o Native Handle fonksiyonunu çağırıp arka planda hep bunlarda Handle sistemi var ya o Handle'ı kullanarak işletim sisteminin fonksiyonlarını kullanabiliyorsunuz.
Yani o tasarım bence güzel bir tasarım.
Böylece size Handle veriyor.
Handle yoluyla işletim sisteminin yine apilerini kullanabiliyorsunuz ama eğer ihtiyaç yoksa da standart kütüphane yetiyor.
Evet burada Çağrı haklı fazla kontroller yapabilirdiler.
Şimdi Çağrı C
Arkadaşlar bu şimdi
Bu da çok tartışılıyor yeni başlayanlar arasında.
Mesela ben
Burada C isimli değişkeni
Acaba burada tanımlamamla
Burada tanımlamam arasında
Yanlış oldu.
Bir fark olur mu?
Yani bazen şöyle düşünüyor.
Derleyicilerin optimizasyonu göz önüne alınmadığı için
İşte döngünler durumda bu değişken yaratılacak.
Döngünün bir sonraki durumda yeniden yaratılacak.
Otomatik ömürlü olduğu için.
Fakat böyle durumlarda
Yine derleyici bunları çok kolay optimize ediyor.
Yani özellikle bu primitif türden değişkenlerin
Efendim döngünler durumda oluşsun
Tekrar hayatı bitsin yerine
Döngünün dışına almak
Bence iyi bir fikir değil.
Neden iyi bir fikir değil?
Çünkü döngünün dışına alınca
Bu sefer
Zaten derleyicinin optimize ettiği kod yerine
Böyle bir kod yazdığınızda
Tahmin edin ne oluşuyor?
O terime
Scope Likic
Bravo aliyamız
Bence Scope Likic
Bundan daha önemli bir problem.
Evet o yüzden
C değişkenini
Yani dosyadan okunacak ve dosyaya yazılacak
Byte değerini tutacak değişkeni
Doğrudan burada tanımlamakta
Bir sakınca görmedim.
Şimdi arkadaşlar
Yine
Ifs'nin get fonksiyonuna
C'yi verdim.
Önce byte byte okuma yapıyorum.
Ve
OutSS
OutSS değil
OFS
İşte değişkenisinde
Put fonksiyonuyla
Yazdım.
Arkadaşlar her yazdığım
Byte için
Byte count değişkenini
Bir arttırdım.
Byte count
Evet
Şimdi
Böylece
Burada
Şuradan şuraya kadar
Bir dosyayı okuyup
Yazma amaçlı dosyaya
Yazmış oldum.
Dolayısıyla
Byte count'ı da bir arttı
Byte count'ı da bir arttı.
Artı artı
Byte count'ı.
Peki bir soru.
Şimdi biliyorsunuz
Önek artı artı operatörüyle
Bunlar çok temel.
Son ek artı artı operatörünün
Yan etkisi arasında
Yani
Değişkenin değerini
Bir arttırması dışında
Arkadaşlar
Bir de
Ne özelliği var?
Ürettiği değer.
Ama ürettiği değeri
Onları biliyorsunuz.
İşte önek olduğu zaman
Nesnenin
Operandın değerinin
Bir fazlası
Son ek olduğunda
Operandın kendi değeri.
Arkadaşlar
Ama yan etkisini
Sadece kullanıyorsam
Yani üretilen değeri
Kullanmıyorsam
Discard ediyorsam
Arkadaşlar ben her zaman
Önek artı artı
Operatörünü kullanıyorum.
Bir de size sorayım.
Siz de benim gibi
Mi kol yazıyorsunuz.
Nedenini
Bu sorunun nedenini
Şimdi söyleyeceğim.
A evet ben de böyle yazıyorum.
Yo
B
Ben tam tersi
Postfix kullanıyorum.
Arkadaşlar
Önek kullanmaya alışmakta
Şöyle bir
Fayda da var.
Şimdi
İteratörler söz konusu olduğunda
Yok yok
Rasul
Yani
Burada önek ve son ek
Primitif değişkenler için
Derleyici onu optimize eder.
Yani o
Temp yaratılıyor falan
Onlar
Primitif türden
Değişkenler için
Hikaye
Ama
İteratörler için
Gerçekten önemli bir fark var.
Yani derleyicinin
Ürettiği koda bakın.
O yüzden madem
İteratörler için
İkisini kullanabiliyorken
Önek'i kullanmak
Daha avantajlı.
Çünkü birinde
Birinde geçirme
Nezle oluşturuluyor.
O zaman
Her zaman
Önek'i kullanmakta
Fayda var.
Çağrı Bey diyor ki
Ben nedenini bilmeden
Kitaplarda öyle
Kullanılıyor diye
Öyle alışmıştım.
Bence iyi bir alışkanlık
Bozmayın da.
Şimdi
Dosyayı
Kapatıyorum.
Arkadaşlar
Bu arada
Dosya işlemlerinde
Yapılan
Çok tipik bir
Hata daha var.
O da şu
Mesela bir dosyadan
Bunu geçen derslerden
Birinde söylemiştim
Ama o dersi
Geçen derslerden
Birinde değil
Son derste
Söylemiş olmalıyım.
Arkadaşlar
Siz dosyayı
Bir dosya üstünde
Diyelim ki
Sizin
Ifstream
Türünden
IFS
İsimli bir
Nesneniz var.
Ama döngüsel bir
Yapı içinde
Ya da birden fazla
Kez
Bununla
Birden fazla
Dosyayı
İşleyeceksiniz.
E şimdi
Diyelim ki
Bir dosyayı
Açtınız
IFS
Open
Efendim
Ali.xyz
Ondan sonra
Bytebyte
Okudunuz
Ama bakın
Bytebyte
Bütün hepsini
Okuduğunuz zaman
Stream
E-off
Durumuna
Geçiyor.
Stream'in
E-off
Durumuna
Geçmesi
Demek
Stream'in
Fail
Olması
Demek.
Dolayısıyla
Stream fail
Olduktan sonra
Stream'i
Bir daha
Kullanabilmek
İçin
Mutlaka
Tekrar
Good
Durumuna
Almanız
Gerekiyor.
Bazı sistemlerde
Bu otomatik
Olarak yapılıyor
Derli için
Ürettiği kodda
Belki ama
Ona güvenmeyin.
Dolayısıyla
Mesela şöyle
Bir kod varsa
Y
I-F-S
Get
C
Sembolik
Alarak
Yazıyorum
Nokta
Ama burada
Bu döngüden
Çıktığında
I-F-S
Artık
Good
Durumunda
Değil.
O yüzden
Tekrar
I-F-S
Nesnesine
Yani yeni bir
If Stream
Nesnesi
Döngünler
Durumunda
Oluşturmuyorsanız
Aynı
If Stream
Nesnesini
Oluşturuyorsanız
Bu durumda
Clear
Fonksiyonunu
Çağırarak
Hata
Bayraklarını
Ne yapmanız
Gerekiyor
Temizlemeniz
Ve dosyayı
Kapattım
Şimdi
Burada
Tipik bir hatada
Mesela
Burada
Uzantısı
Para olan
Dosyayı
Sileceğim ya
Remove
Fonksiyonunu
Burada
Çağırsaydım
Muhtemelen
Dosya
Silinemeyecekti
Ve
Tanımsız
Davranışta
Oluşacaktı
Programın
Çalışması
Devam ettiği için
Ya da
Ben
Devam etmeye
Zorladığım için
O yüzden
Dosyanın
Silinmesinden
Önce
Arkadaşlar
Dosyanın
Kapalı
Olduğuna
Dikkat edin
Tipik
İdiyomuz
C'de
Böyle
Yazıyoruz
Stood
Remove
Parametresi
Bakın
Şimdi
Cstr
Fonksiyonunun
Ne
Kadar
Faydalı
Olduğunu
Görüyoruz
Çünkü
Bu
C
Fonksiyonu
Bunun
String
Overloadu
Yok
Dolayısıyla
Ne
Yapmam
Gerekiyor
Arkadaşlar
Burada
O
S
Neydi
İsmi
Out
S
Evet
Out
S
Bunun
Arkadaşlar
Str'sinin
C
Str'si
Fonksiyonu
Şimdi
Buralarda
Tabii
Söylenecek
Çok şey
Var
Ufak
Tefek
Mesela
Bir
Tanesi
Eğer
Birden
Fazla
Kez
Kullanacaksam
Hem
Kodun
Okunmasını
Daha
Kolay
Hale
Getirmek
İçin
Hem
Burada
Derleyici
Bir
Optimizasyon
Yapmazsa
Str'si
Fonksiyonu
Tekrar
Çağrılacak
Geri
Dönüş
Değeri
Referans
Olmadığı
İçin
Yine
Bir
String
Nesnesi
Oluşturulacak
Ona
Karşı
Bir
Önlem
Almak
İçin
Belki
Arkadaşlar
Şurada
Bunu
Bir
Değişken
İsimlendirmek
De
Fayda
Olabilir
Ama
Şimdi
Konumuz
Bu
Değil
Peki
Bu
Videomu
Tabii
Herkes
Biliyor
Çünkü
Remove
Arkadaşlar
Bir tane
Parantez
Fazla
Oldu
Galiba
Remove
Naziro
Dönersek
Başarısız
Demektir
Oraya
Da
Bir
Hata
Mesajı
Verelim
Stud
C
L
Efendim
Dosya
Silinemedi
Tabii
Dosyanın
İsmini
De
Yazdırabilirdim
Değil mi
Bakın
Bu
Sefer
Üçüncü
Kez
Dosya
İsmini
Kullanmış
Olacaktım
Neyse
Şöyle
Diyelim
En azından
Hata
Anın
Dosyanın
Silinememesi
İle
İlgili
Olduğunu
Bir
Gösterelim
En son
Verdiğim
Return
Kodundan
Bir
Fazlasını
Vereyim
Return
Üç
Arkadaşlar
Başka da bir şey
Gerekmiyor
Kaçırdığım
Bir şey
Varsa
Siz
Söyleyin
Ama
Yine
Bilgilendirici
Yazı
Vermek
İstiyorum
Diyeyim ki
Stud
C
Out
File
Adet
Dosya
Byte
ARGV
1'di değil mi?
ARGV1
dosyası
olarak
birleştirildi.
İsterliyorum.
Bir uyarı mesajı, bir error yok.
Rebotic yapayım.
Konut satırına gideyim.
Şimdi görüyorsunuz
23 tane uzantısı para olan dosya var.
Bulde ona bakalım.
Sonra
bir yıldız nokta ekse
işte bizim en son yazdığımız programın eksesi
a nokta ekse
rename
dos
1 nokta ekse
evet dosyası
şimdi
biz şu ne gün
ekseği
bölmüştük.
Bunu tekrar hatırlatalım mı?
Ne gün?
Efendim
12 Mayıs
gün sonrası
Karşamba günüymüş
27 Temmuz
Pazartesi'ymiş.
yani dosyaları birleştirdiğimiz zaman
eğer yazdığımız kodda bir hata yoksa
birleştirilmiş dosyayı çalıştırdığımızda
bunun gibi çalışmalı.
Çünkü böldüğümüz dosya buydu.
hadi
dos 1
ne olsun
arkadaşlar
vday
ne
isim çakışması da olmasın
wd
nokta
ekse
evet
bakalım
kontrol edelim
23 adet dosya
byte'lık
ki doğru
mouse'ı takip edin
nvd
ekse dosyası olarak
birleştirildi.
Bir
yıldız
nokta
ekse
işte bakın
nvd
nokta
ekse
byte
arkadaşlar
ve
ne gün nokta
ekse
byte
bir de
dosyalar silinmiş mi?
Bir
yıldız
nokta
par
gördüğünüz gibi
par uzantılı dosya
kalmamış.
O zaman
birleşmiş dosya
ne ismini vermiştik?
nvd
aynı şekilde
formatı bozulmamış olması gerekiyor.
Birebir aynı olması gerekiyor.
Yine de deneyelim.
nvd
ocak
den
arkadaşlar
gün sonrası
22 ocak
çarşamba
ve yine
bakın ki
rastlantıya
10 Mart
yine
çarşamba
günü.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
dosyalarla ilgili
biraz daha konuşacağım
ama çok değil.
Ondan sonra
önemli bir altbaşlık
bence.
Hocam
threadlere
tahmini
kaç ders sonra
geçeceğiz?
Arkadaşlar
tahmini
4-5 ders
sonra
diyelim.
bu tür durumlarda
ben diyorum
3 vakte kadar
çünkü tam olarak
öngöremiyorum.
Bazı dersler
benim tahminimden
biraz daha uzun sürüyor.
Bazıları biraz daha kısa sürüyor.
Ama
göreceğiz sonuçta.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
biraz daha dosyalarla
ilgili konuşacağım.
ondan sonra
şimdi bir zamanda
o stream iteratör
sınıfını
görmüştük.
Ama en az
onun kadar önemli
en az
onun kadar
faydalı
bir de
iStream iteratör
sınıfı var.
sınıfını da
anlatacağım.
Ve ondan
sonra da
hem
artık
C++'ın
standart
kütüphanesinin
her tarafına
nüfuz ettiği için
hem de
özellikle
concurrency
tarafında da
kullandığımız için
krono kütüphanesini
anlatacağım.
Evet
o zaman
gidişat
böyle diyelim.
Saatimize de bakalım.
Evet
daha vaktimiz var.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi bu
geçen derste
bir şey göstermiştim.
Şu
giriş tarafındaki
skip
white space
manipülatörü
o
yarım kaldı.
Bakın şimdi
şu skip
white space'i
göstereyim.
Bazı
manipülatörler
hangi
fonksiyonun
çağrıldığıyla
ilgili.
Mesela
skip
white space
manipülatörü
normalde
iStream
nesnelere
okuma işlemlerinde
arkadaşlar
formatlı okuma
işlemlerinde
no skip
white space
durumunda.
No skip
white space
ne demek?
Hemen bir örnek
verelim.
Şunları da
sileyim.
Arkadaşlar
mesela burada
bir dosyayı
açalım.
Neutility
dosyasını
açalım.
Bu sefer
direktifimi
kullanıyorum.
ifstream
ifs
örneği
baştan
sonra takip
edin.
Arkadaşlar
new
t
nokta
ha
if
ifs
fail
efendim
CRR
bir de
onu anlatmamış
olabilirim
bir de
CLog
nesnesi var.
CRR ile
CLog arasındaki
fark
birinin
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
yazması
bufferlama
sistemini
kullanmadan
yani bufferlamayı
bypass ederek
doğrudan
yazıyor.
İşte bakın
onu da
ayarlayabiliyorsunuz.
Orada da
unitbuff
manipülatörü
var.
Şimdi
onu da
madem
yeri geldi
onu da
o kısa
anlatayım.
Tekrar
buraya
geri
döneceğim.
Arkadaşlar
bu
formatlama
özellikleri
ve
o stream
manipülatörleri
ya da
i-stream
manipülatörleri
söz konusu
olduğunda
ben
hepsini
anlatmadığımı
çünkü
zaman yetmez
ama
yeri geldiğinde
anlatmadığım
bir
manipülatörü
ya da
formatlama
özelliğini
hatırlarsam
yani
önemli olduğunu
düşünürsem
sonra anlatacağım
söylemiştim.
Bakın şimdi
bunlardan bir tanesi
ios'un
arkadaşlar
unitbuff'ı
bu önemli.
Şimdi
bunun karşılığı
bir de
unitbuff
manipülatörü
var.
Mesela
see out
unitbuff
no unitbuff
yine aynı şekilde
örneğin
arkadaşlar
see out
set f
efendim
ios'un
unitbuff'ı
ya da
set f
arkadaşlar
anset f
ios'un
unitbuff'ı
gibi.
Şimdi
default olarak
streamler
unitbuff
modunda
değil
arkadaşlar.
Unitbuff ne demek?
Unitbuff
ne demek?
Bu şu
normalde bir
bufferlama var
side anlatıyorum.
Yani siz dosyaya
şey yazdığınız zaman
doğrudan
device'a gitmiyor.
O dosya için
oluşturulmuş bir buffer
var.
Bir bellek alanı var.
O bellek alanına
yazılıyor.
ama bazı
olaylar
tetiklendiğinde
bazı eventler
gerçekleştiğinde
o buffer
flash ediliyor.
İşte bunu
antl manipülatörüyle ilgili
o tipik yapılması gereken
uyarıya
yaparken
anlatmıştım.
Antl
is not
putting
a new line.
Çünkü
antl
aslında bir de
stream'i
flash ediyor.
İşte bakın
o stream
ne zaman
flash ediliyor?
Stream'in
flash edilmesi için
ya o buffer'ın
dolması gerekiyor
ya
flash fonksiyonunun
çağrılması
gerekiyor
ya programın
normal
terminate edilmesi
gerekiyor.
Bu da önemli.
Arkadaşlar
normal
terminate edilmesi
gerekiyor.
Abnormal
termination'da
o garanti
yok.
İşte bir takım
eventler
oraya çok fazla
girmek istemiyorum.
Çoğunlukla
side anlatmış
oluyorum.
buffer'ın
flash edilmesini
sağlıyor.
Ama şöyle bir mod
da var.
Yani ben
buffer'lama falan
istemiyorum.
Verdiğim
doğrudan
stream'e
yazılsın.
İşte o zaman
normalde
biliyorsunuz
bunu
side yapmak
için
sinin
standart
bitmanesini
hatırlayanlar
arkadaşlar
orada
set ve
buff fonksiyonu
var.
Onunla
yapıyoruz değil mi?
Yani buffer'lama
parametrelerini
değiştirmek için.
Fakat burada
stream'i
unit buff moduna
çekerseniz
yani şu
çareyi yaparsınız
cout
setf
ios'un
unit buff'ı
şu demek
her yazma
işleminde
artık
doğrudan
stream'e
yazacak.
Yani buffer'lamayı
bas geçecek.
şimdi ama
diğer manipülatörde
böylece aklıma geldiği için
unit buff manipülatörünü de
anlatmış oldum.
Diğer manipülatörde
skip
white space.
Bu da şu
demek.
Formatlı yazım
işlemlerinde
normalde
bir arkadaşımın mikrofonu açık kalmış olabilir.
Formatlı yazım işlemlerinde
normalde white space karakterler atlanmıyor.
Arkadaşlar
formatlı okuma işlemlerinde özür dilerim.
Ama siz
onların
atlanmasını istiyorsanız
pardon
önemli değildiniz
onların atlanmasını istiyorsanız
o zaman
skip white space modunu alacaksınız stream'i.
Skip white space
modu
default modu olmadığı için
şöyle bir çağrı yapmanız gerekiyor.
İşte stream
setf
arkadaşlar
no
skip
white space
anlaşıldı değil mi?
setf
evet
pardon özür dilerim
setf
ios'un
ansetf
evet
skip vs
ya da
ansetf
skip vs
ama bunun bir de manipülatörü var.
O zaman da şöyle stream
tabi bu
i-stream manipülatörü olduğu için
şöyle
skip white space
ya da
no skip white space
diyeceksiniz.
Peki
o zaman bunu bir örnek üstüne gösterelim demek
demiştik.
Zaten orada
konuyu değiştirdim.
Biraz daha attım.
Tekrar oraya geri döndüm.
Evet
if stream
sınıfı
önünden
ifs'i
arkadaşlar
siyere
işte yazalım
bir şekilde
dosya
açılamadı.
Return
bir
şimdi bakın
format dokunma yapacağım.
charge
while
ifs
c
so
see out
using
direct
in var
see out
put
c
şimdi kodun çalışmasına bakın
arkadaşlar
hatta
evet
şöyle yapalım
burada
dosper.txt
varmış
onu
yazdıralım
daha küçük bir dosya
dosper.txt
derliyorum
bakın şimdi
arkadaşlar
white space
bu karakterleri
izleyin
tekrar bakalım
evet
ipsc
ekran çıktısını gördünüz
değil mi
bakın
boşluk karakterleri
ama
no skip vs
ifs
arkadaşlar
ifs'ydi değil mi
no skip vs
skip vs
skip
white space
no skip
işte bu işlemde
ben başka bir
hata yapmamışsam
evet gördünüz
arkadaşlar
no skip
white space
modunu aldığım zaman
boşluk karakterlerine
ne yaptı
atlamadı
evet
yani
formatlı okumada
hem belki tersi
söylemiş olabilirim
default'u
white space'leri
atlama
tıpkı
tabi zaten
böyle olması lazım
nasıl
ben
int değerleri okurken
boşlukları dikkate
almıyorsa
ama boşlukları
atlamaması için
no skip
white space
modunu
almam gerekiyor
ama bu formatlı
okumada
yani örneğin
get fonksiyonunu
çağırsaydım
skip vs
no skip vs
etkilenmeyecekti
boşluk karakterlere
her zaman
alınacaktı
evet bunu da
söylemiş olalım
arkadaşlar şimdi
bu sınıfların
okuma ve yazma
tarafında
baya bir
overload
overloadları da
olan
fonksiyonları var
şimdi ben o fonksiyonların
hepsini
gösterme şansına da
sahip değilim
çok zaman gider
artık bir kısmına
cppreference.com'dan
bakacaksınız
ama şöyle bir
genel bilgi
vermek
gerekirse
getline isimli
fonksiyonlar var
hem sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
hem de
örneğin
stop string için
global fonksiyon
get isimli
fonksiyonlar var
örneğin bir
char diziye
okuma yapmak için
ya da bir
char değişkeni
set etmek için
bir kısmını
görmüştük
arkadaşlar
read write
fonksiyonları var
binary
olarak
arkadaşlar
özellikle
binary dosyaları
üstüne işlem yaparken
dosyadan
ram'den
dosyaya
transfer yapan
onun dışında
bir de
read some
isimli bir fonksiyonu var
o overloadlara
arkadaşlar
bakmanız
gerekiyor
hocam
dos böyle
binary yerine
tx modunda
okumak
tehlikeli değil mi
tabi tabi ama
windows da özellikle
tehlikeli
onu geçen
derste söylemiştim
kesinlikle
haklısınız
arkadaşlar
bir iki noktayı
da hatırlatmak istiyorum
yine geçen dersin
sonlarına gelmişti
biri
formatsız okuma
fonksiyonları
stream nesnesini
döndürdüğü için
referans semantiğiyle
kaç byte okudu
sorusunun cevabını
geri dönüş
değeriyle
vermiyordu
ama
sınıfın bir
gcount
isimli fonksiyonu
vardı
gcount
isimli fonksiyon
son okuma
işleminde
formatsız okuma
kaç byte
okunmuş
onu
veriyordu
şimdi gelelim
bir iki tane
bu az önce
ismini saydım
fonksiyonların
hepsini göstermeyeceğim
dedim ama
bir iki tanesine
değineyim
mesela çar diziye
okuma yapmak
istiyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
yani okumayı
bir çar diziye
yapmak istiyorsunuz
aslında şuraya kadar
silmeyelim
evet
bakınız
şimdi
dosbor.tx de
bu
dolayısıyla
okuma yaparken
ilk
şu
karakterleri
okuyacak
evet
şimdi ben
diyelim ki
bir çar dizim var
çar
buff
ne olsun
100 olsun
ve
dosyadan
arkadaşlar
bir satır
okumak isteyeyim
şimdi bu tür fonksiyonların
hep yapısı
bu
c'de de böyle
fgetz fonksiyonunu
hatırlayın
get line fonksiyonu
zaten
içinde
line geçenler
new line'ı
new olarak
alıyorlar
arkadaşlar
delimiter olarak
alıyorlar
evet
adresi veriyorum
bir de
tam sayı değeri
veriyorum
stream size türünden
ona da tipik olarak
dizinin boyutunu
veriyoruz
std değil
buff ismini
vermişim
evet
böylece
bu tür fonksiyonlar
şöyle çalışıyor
başka örnekleri de var
yine kütüphanede
get line'ların
eğer
100 karakter
okuyamadan
new line'ı
okursak
arkadaşlar
new line'ı
yazmıyor
ama
orada
duruyor
yani
diziyi
taşırma riski yok
ve bu
tabi ki
null karakteri de
yazıyor
bunun
çünkü
char dizi olduğu için
null terminated
olması gerekiyor
mesela
gerçekten
get line
fonksiyonunu
çağırdıktan sonra
iki şeyi test edelim
biri
gcount fonksiyonuyla
kaç byte
okunduğuna
bakalım
cout
efendim
neydi
stream nesnemi
ismi
ifs
gcount
byte
okundu
bu bir
ikincisi
cout
köle boşlukları
new line'ı
falan da görmek için
type karakterleri
arasında
fonttaki
gestring
yazdıralım
şimdi
bakınız
değerli edin
çalıştırıyorum
20 byte
okundu
aslında ne
arkadaşlar
0 1 2 3 4 5
6 7
8 9 10
11 12
bir de new line'ı da okuyor
onu da
stream'in buffer'ından
extract ediyor
böylece
20 çıkıyor
ama
mesela
bakınız
20 ya
10 yapalım
programı tekrar çalıştırıyorum
arkadaşlar
9 byte okundu
neden
çünkü taşırmamak için
9 byte zaten
dizinin boyutunu
veriyorum
ve 10.
karakter olarak da
null karakteri yazdı
dolayısıyla bu
get line fonksiyonlarının
o dizi boyutu isteyen
parametresi
neyi önlüyor
arkadaşlar
taşırmayı
önlüyor
şimdi bir de
şu
dosya konum göstericisinden
file pointer'dan
bahsedelim
arkadaşlar
şimdi c tarafını
bir hatırlamanızı istiyorum
c tarafında
aslında
şu fonksiyonlar var
f-seek
bu arada şöyle bir durum da
oluştu
benzem benim öğrencilerimden de
oluyor
sizin aranızda da öyle
arkadaşlarım varsa
yani bu derste
canlı katına
söylesinler
şimdi bazı arkadaşlar
eskiden böyle değildi
önce c++
öğreniyorlar
yani
onlar
c++'ın
içindeki
c gibi
bakmıyorlar
yani c++
dilini
baştan bir şekilde
öğreniyorlar
iyi kötü
ama
bu durumda
c++'ın
içindeki c'ye
odaklandıkları için
c dilinde
yetersiz oluyorlar
mesela öyle arkadaşlar
katıldığında
eğlenceli oluyor
diyor ki
Resul Bey diyor ki
ben öyleyim
olabilir
o arkadaşlar
katıldığında
mesela ben bu derste
işte
f-c2'ye
şuna buna gönderme
yapıyorum ya
Alihan
Resul
onlar
belki sizin için
de böyle
Allah Allah
nedir bu
f-c falan
diye düşünüyorlar
çünkü onlar
işe gereği
c kodu da yazmıyor
ama bence
ideali
c++
programcılarının
c'ye de
hakim olmaları
yani bence
bu iyi
çünkü
birçok yerde de
mesela c ve c++
birlikte kullanılabiliyor
bir de
her ne kadar
yanlış olsa da
bu Nespers
artık o kadar
çok yapıldı ki
ben yapmayacağım
hep şöyle yazıyorlar ya
iş ilanlarında
LinkedIn'de bakın
biri
ilanda c c++
bilen falan
deyince
hemen altına
bir iki kişi
çakıyor
böyle bir şey yok
c c++
bunlar ayrı
programlama
diri diye
evet
ama
yani burada
kast edilen
tabii
hem c de
hem c++
da
kod
yazabilen
evet
Abdülkadir Bey
diyor ki
sadece c kullanılsa da
c++
istiyorlar
evet
ya onlar da
şöyle düşünüyor
zaten işte
ekonomik koşullar
Türkiye'de de
belli
madem biz eleman
alacağız
bari
c
ah ne
aynısı
biraz tabii
komik olacak
ama
gerçek
ya ona da
aynı parayı
vereceğiz
buna da
aynı parayı
vereceğiz
almışken
sadece c
bileni değil
aynı zamanda
c++
bileni de
alalım
hocam
asm yazmanızı
gerektirecek
bir durum
oldu mu
eğer soru
şuysa
yani
c kodu içinde
ya da c++
kodu içinde
asm yazmanızı
gerektiren
durum oldu mu
eskiden oldu
ama şimdi
şunu söyleyeyim
halen öyle
ihtiyaçlar
var mı
var
yani belirli
alanlarda
inline
assembly
kullanmanız
gerekebilir
ama
yani
eskiden
belki bu oran
çok daha
yüksekti
ama şimdi
artık
10 sene
15 sene
20 sene
öncesine
kadar
o zaman
assembly
arkadaşlar
derleyici
optimizasyonları
bu kadar
gelişmiş
değildi
belki o nedenle
daha etkin
kod oluşturmak
için
inline
assembly
kullanabiliyordunuz
ya da
belki
assembly
yapıp
ama
c tarafında
yapamayacağınız
bir işlem
olduğu için
ama şimdi
onlar
son derece
azaldı
bu arada
bizim
siyi derneğinde
senede bir kere
ya açılıyor
ya açılmıyor
ama çok meraklısı için
çok güzel bir
assembly kursu da var
arkadaşlar
evet
peki
şimdi
şu
şeyden
bahsedecektim
ya
assembly
de öğrenmemizi
tercih eder misiniz
kesinlikle tercih ederim
yani
ama bunlar da
arkadaşlar
zaman meselesi
şimdi
öğrenilecek
o kadar çok şey
var ki
insanlar da
haklı olarak
zamanlarını
kendi
durumlarına
uygun
önceliklendiriyorlar
yani şimdi
mesela diyelim ki
yapay zeka tarafında
çalışıyorsanız
C++'ı
o alanda
kullanacaksınız
bu yapay zeka
makine öğrenmesi
derya deniz
ona mı zaman
ayıracağım
assembly mi zaman
yani çok iyi bir
zaman yönetimiyle
herhalde
doğru olan
kişinin
ihtiyaçlarına
öncelik
vermek
çağrı
modern
C++'a mı
hakim olalım
STL'in kentisi
zaten derya deniz
C'ye mi
hakim olalım
biz ne yapalım
diyor
arkadaşım
arkadaşlar
aslında bakın
C küçük bir dil
yani
C++
öğrendikten sonra
C'yi öğrenmek
çok kolay
zaten büyük ölçüde
biliyorsunuz
eksik olan yerleri
çok rahat
kapatabilirsiniz
zor olan
C
programcısına
C++'a geçmesi
yani
benim
tespitime göre
diyelim
C ile C++
arasında
yani
en az 10 kat
ama
büyük ihtimalle
20 kata kadar
çıkan
bir büyüklük
farkı var
dolayısıyla
C++
bilenin
biraz çabayla
C öğrenmesi de
zaten
C++'ın
içindeki
C'yi biliyor
çok fazla
zaman almıyor
o yüzden
bu mesela
çağrı
eğer bu durumda
olan arkadaşım
varsa
Rasul Bey gibi
en fazla
bir ay diyorum
bir ay
günde bir saat
bir buçuk saat
bakın
mesela benim
C kursu
200 saat
o kursu
şimdi
izleseniz
büyük ihtimalle
bilmediğiniz şeyler
de karşınıza
çıkacak
ama bildiğiniz
yerler de
çok olacak
yani
%50
belki
mesela
C++'da
mallop
fonksiyonunu
çağırmıyorsunuz
ama C'de
dinamik bellek yönetimi
tarafında
mallop nedir
callop nedir
rallop nedir
bunlar nasıl çalışıyor
free fonksiyonu
ne yapıyor
vesaire
bütün bunları
öğrenmeniz
gerekiyor
şimdi ben bir şey
şu konuyu bitireyim
çok da fazla
uzatmak istemiyorum
bakın buradaki
fonksiyonlar
bunlar
Fseek
Fseek'in özel
biçimi
rewind
dosya konum
göstericisini
dosyanın
başına çekiyor
Ftel
ben dosya
konum
göstericisi
isterken
İngilizce
file pointer
teriminin
türçesi
olarak
kullanıyorum
ve
bir de
have set
post
have get
şimdi
örnek yapacağım
ama önce anlatayım
bakın
C++'da
böyle değil
stream
sınıflarının
if stream
off stream
ya da
f stream
sınıflarından
hangisi
olduğuna
bağlı olarak
Fseek'in
karşılığı
arkadaşlar
efendim
Cg
ve
Cp
fonksiyonları
var
okuma
tarafında
get'in
g'si
yani
dosya konum
göstericisini
konumlandırmak
için
Cg
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
off stream
tarafında
da
Cp
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
benzer şekilde
dosya konum
göstericisinin
file pointer'ın
değerini get etmek
için
okuma
tarafında
fg
fonksiyonunu
yazma
tarafında
fp
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
yalnız
burada
C
fonksiyonlarının
iki tane
overloadu
var
bir
overloadu
C'deki
fc gibi
çalışıyor
C'deki
fc
hatırlayın
arkadaşlar
birinci parametre
dosyayla ilişkinizi
sağlayacak
handle
ikinci parametre
long
değer
üçüncü parametre
origin
burada
üç tane
sembolik
sabit var
cxet
ccur
ve
ccant
bunları
biliyor musunuz
en azından
c tarafında
da kod
yazan
arkadaşlar
ne yapıyor
ccur
dosya
konum göstericisini
dosyanın
başından
itibaren
yani dosyanın
başını
orijinal olarak
alıp
konumlandırıyor
cxet
ckant
dosyanın
sonunu
orijinal olarak
alıp
konumlandırıyor
ccur
de
dosyanın
dosya
konum göstericisini
file pointer'ın
son değerini
kullanıyor
o yüzden
şu çağrıları
c'de çok iyi
bilmeniz gerekiyor
mesela dosya
konum göstericisini
file pointer'ı
dosyanın
başına
çekeceğim
fc
f
l
arkadaşlar
cxet
mesela dosya
konum göstericisini
dosyanın
başına
çekeceğim
geri dönüş
değerine
ihtiyacım
yoksa
rewind
f
dosya
konum göstericisini
dosyanın
sonundan
bunlar
linux'teki
sistem
kolları mı
kesinlikle
dosya
konum göstericisini
dosyanın
sonundan
geri alacağım
fc
f
eksi
long
ckant
dosya
konum göstericisini
dosyanın
sonuna
çekeceğim
böylece
diyelim ki
dosyanın
büyüklüğünü
elde edeceğim
o zaman
fc
f
long
ck
and
arkadaşlar
ve
burada
aman dikkat
dosya
konum göstericisini
en son
bulunduğu
yerden
geri alacağım
eksi
long
ck
kör
current
ya da
ck
kör
ileri
alacağım
yine ck
ama pozitif
değer
yani geri alırken
negatif
değer
ileri alırken
pozitif
değer
ama bir de
meşhur
bu çağrı var
hatırlayan var mı
bu çağrıyı
fc
f
ck
zaten
nihai konumu
orijin olarak
al demek
bu da aslında
ne anlama geliyor
dosya konum göstericisini
bulunduğu değerde bırak
şimdi bu çağrının
önemini programcılar
genel olarak
bilmiyorlar
ve tanımsız davranış
oluşuyor
tanımsız davranış
oluştuğu için
arkadaşlar
hatanın nedenini
de bulamıyorlar
ama aslında
hikaye şöyle
bakalım kaç kişi
hatırlayacak
arkadaşlar
şimdi
şuradan boş
bir sayfa
alalım
şu bizim
dosyamızdaki
arkadaşlar
byte'lar
yani bunların
byte byte olduğunu
düşünün
şu bizim
file pointer'ımız
file pointer'ın
ne olduğunu
hatırlıyoruz
değil mi
file pointer aslında
bir tam sayı
değişken
onun değeri
kaç ise
okuma fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız zaman
o index
byte'den
o app
offset'ten
başlayarak
okuyor
yazma fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız zaman
o index
den
başlayarak
yazıyor
yani
örneğin
c'deki
okuma ya da
yazma fonksiyonları
dosyanın
neresinden
okuyayım
kaçıncı
byte'ından
başlayarak
okuyayım
sorusunun
cevabını
herhangi bir
parametreye
istemiyorlar
çünkü onu
zaten
ulaştıkları
file pointer'dan
alıyorlar
okuma işlemi
yapan fonksiyonlar
okuyan fonksiyonlar
okudukları
byte sayısı
kadar
file pointer'ı
arttırıyor
mesela bu noktadan
okuma işlemi yapan
bir fonksiyonu
çağırıp
çağrı
20 byte
okusam
file pointer
ileri gidecek
bir daha
30 byte
okusam
ileri gidecek
aynı şekilde
yazma fonksiyonu
diyelim ki
buradaki
byte'ları
değiştirdim
10 byte
yazdım
bu da
10 ileri
gitti
20 byte
yazdım
20 ileri
gitti
ama maalesef
alt seviyeli
bu işletim
sisteminden
kaynaklanan
nedenlerle
şöyle bir
problem var
diyelim ki
siz önce
okuma işlemi
yaptınız
fakat ondan sonra
yazma işlemi
yapacaksınız
benim tabirimle
okumadan
yazmaya
geçeceksiniz
ya da tam tersi
yazma işlemi
yaptınız
yazma işleminden
sonra
okuma işlemi
yapacaksınız
bakın o zaman
şöyle bir durum
oluşuyor
diyelim ki
20 byte
okudum
dosya konum
göstericisi
arttı
fakat
zaten de
buraya yazmak
istiyorum
ne yapıyor
programcı
bunu bilmediği
için
tak diye
burada yazma
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
ve tanımsız
davranış
oluşuyor
okumadan
yazmaya
ve yazmadan
okumaya
geçişte
aynı yere
yazmak
isteseniz
dahi
yine
file pointer'ı
set etmeniz
gerekiyor
işte böyle
durumlarda
bakın tekrar
söylüyorum
bu kadar
okudum
ama şimdi
buraya yazacağım
o zaman
tekrar
bu
c'deki
dosya
fonksiyonlarına
gidelim
böyle bir
çağrı
yapmanız
gerekiyor
şimdi
gelelim
işimizin
sonuna
bizim
f-seek
fonksiyonlarımızın
karşılığı
s-seek
arkadaşlar
ne dedik
s-ge ve
s-p fonksiyonlarımız
var
arkadaşlar
ama
burada
iki tane
overload var
mesela
bakınız
izleyin
en azından
gösterelim
şimdi
birinci
overload
şöyle
ifs
s-ge
bakın
fonksiyonu
var mı
yok
ama
off stream
olsaydı
ya da
off stream
olsaydı
s-ge
fonksiyonu
da olacaktı
ifs
s-ge
şimdi
iki
overloada
bakın
arkadaşlar
bir tane
overloadın
bir tek
parametresi
var
stream
post türünden
post türü
yine bir
tam sayı
türünün
eş
ismi
ve
s-ge
fonksiyonu
ne yapıyor
diyelim ki
buna
bin
geçseniz
dosya konum
göstericisinin
değerini
bin
yapıyor
yani
burada
orijin
falan
yok
5 derseniz
5.
offset
çıkıyor
5 indekse
100 derseniz
100.
indekse
çekiyor
tabi ki
yine
burada
başarısızlık
söz konusu
olduğunda
stream yine
fail
durumuna
düşüyor
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
yine
yıldız
dizi
olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
fakat
ikinci
overload
arkadaşlar
farklı
birinci parametresi
stream
offset
türünden
ki bu
pozitif
ya da
negatif
değer
olabilir
ikinci
parametresi
eş
ismi
telaffuz
etmek
istemiyorum
çünkü
başka bir yere
gidebilir
şöyle
telaffuz
edeyim
seek
directory
direction
özür dilerim
seek
direction
ama doğrudan
standart
kütüphanın
verdiği
eş
ismi
okumak
istemiyorum
tahmin edebileceğiniz
nedenden
ama işte
burada
fonksiyonun
ikinci parametresi
bu
demin neden
c'nin
standart fonksiyonlarını
anlattığımı
daha iyi anlayacaksınız
çünkü bu tıpkı
ne gibi çalışıyor
çağrı
c'deki
efsik gibi
çalışıyor
yani ikinci parametreye
3 tane sabitten
sabitten birini vereceksiniz
biri
arkadaşlar
IOS'un
bagi
diğeri
IOS'un
endi
diğeri
IOS'un
körü
yani örneğin
şöyle çağırırsanız
ck30
IOS'un
bagi
bu tıpkı
az önceki
efsikli olduğu gibi
IOS
bag sabiti
dosya konum göstericisini
five pointer'ı
dosyanın başından itibaren
konumlandırma isteği
bu durumda
birinci parametreye
geçtiğiniz değer
pozitif değer olmalı
eğer
IOS'un
endini çağırırsanız
o zaman
dosyanın sonundan
itibaren
konumlandırma yapıyorsunuz
örneğin
five pointer'ı
dosyanın sonuna çekmek için
böyle bir çağrı
yapabilirsiniz
bir de
IOS'un
körü
işte o da
bizim efsikdeki
az önce anlattığım üzere
arkadaşlar
dosya konum göstericisinin
five pointer'ın
en son
konumu
bakın şimdi
ne yapacağız
izleyin
tam
21'de ara vereceğim
bu arada
bakın şimdi ne yapacağız
benim geçen derste
o ders akıtlarını
arkadaşlar hatırlayacaklar
oluşturduğum
bazı dosyalar var
mesela
primes.dat
görüyorsunuz
kilobayt
şimdi
primes.dat
binary bir dosya
ve
ilk bilmem kaç
asal sayıya
hatırlamıyorum
391 kilobayt olduğuna göre
4 milyon
ilk 1 milyon
asal sayıya taşıyordu
geçen derste
örnekler yaptık
dosyayı da biz oluşturduk
bakın şimdi
çok basit bir örnek
ipstream
ifs
efendim
primes.dat
çok dikkatli izleyin
arkadaşlar
ios binary
dosya açılamazsa
dosya açılamadı
yazayım
şimdi dosya açıldı ya
arkadaşlar bakın
cout
ifs
terge
bakın
terge fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş değeri olan
tam sayıyı
yazdırıyorum
cout'un
neden altını çizdi
ios stream dahil edilmiş
tamam şimdi
çizmedik
yavaş yavaş
her birinde ayrıca
diva geçeceğim
çalıştırıyorum
dosya açıldığında
doğal olarak
c'de olduğu gibi
file pointer'ın
değeri
sıfır
şimdi bakın
ifs
cg
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu birinci overload
ve tergeyi çağırıyorum
300'e konumlandırdım
tabii ki
tergeyi de 300'e
ama şimdi bakın
ifs
cg
arkadaşlar
sıfır
ios'un
end'i
buradaki
ios'un end'i
cg
underscore
dir
türünden
arkadaşlar
bir sabit
dosya konum göstericisini
dosyanın sonuna
konumlandırdım
böyle bir çağrı
neden yapılıyor olabilir
mesela en tipik
nedenlerden biri
dosyada
kaç byte olduğunu
tespit etmek için
şimdi tergeye fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
4 milyon
eğer bu
bahsettiğim gibi
1 milyon
asal sayıyı taşıyorsa
4 milyon
değerini döndürecek
gördünüz mü
evet
böylece
cg'nin
2 overloadunu
ve tergeyi
gördük
bir ara verelim
saat
21.01
21.20
de devam edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
özellikle bu
file pointer'ı
set etme
get etme
gibi işlemler
bir dosyayı
look up table
olarak
kullanma
tarafında da
işe yarıyor
şimdi
bazen
oluşturmak istediğimiz
look up table'lar
belliğe sığmıyor
ya da o kadar
alanımız yok
mesela bakınız
burada
rhymes.dat
az önce gördüğünüz gibi
bir önceki
derste
oluşturmuştuk
ilk 1 milyon
asal sayıyı
tacıyordu
ama tabi
binary olarak
şimdi bakın
diyelim ki
bizim sık sık
indekslerle
çok büyük
asal sayılara da
indeksiyle
erişmemiz
gerekiyor
örneğin
456.517.
asal sayı
bunu
bir değişkenimiz
tutuyor olsun
arkadaşlar
evet
yani bir değişkenimiz
o asal sayının
indeksini
tutuyor olsun
mesela
size
d
ne diyelim
idx
t out
kaçıncı asal sayı
tabi yani
yazdığınız programı
mantığı içinde
bu
gerekiyor
olsun
mesela ben
bu
good'da
şöyle basit
bir uygulama
yapmıştım
orada
widget'lar var ya
slider
widget'ı var
kullanıcı
slider'ı
çektikçe
sıfırla
diyelim ki
10 milyon
arasında
herhangi bir sayı
slider'ı
çekiyor
bir yerde
bırakıyor
oradan
indeksi alıyor
biraz da şey
olsun diye
textbox
değil de
input'u
slider'dan
alıyor
slider'ı
hareket ettikçe
diyelim ki
pencerede
o indeksteki
asal sayı
görünüyor
bir pencerede
asal sayının
indeksi
bir başka
pencerede
asal sayının
ne olduğu
mesela öyle bir
program olduğunu
düşünün
e şimdi
ne yapmam
gerekir
ben
idx
kaçıncı
asal sayı
idx demeyelim
de n
diyelim
kaçıncı
asal sayı
olduğu
değerine
bağlı
olarak
file pointer'ı
oraya
konumlandırıp
oradan
okuma
yaparsam
tabi
formatsız
okumadan
bahsediyorum
o asal sayının
ne olduğunu
get edebilirim
onun için
hangi fonksiyonu
çağıracağım
arkadaşlar
ifs'nin
sig
g fonksiyonu
çağıracağım
peki
nereye
konumlandırmam
gerekiyor
tabi ki
indekste
sayma sayısı
arasındaki
farka
bakın
birinci asal sayı
sıfır
indeksinde
dolayısıyla
n-1
çarpı
arkadaşlar
size of
int
öyle değil mi
böylece
m-1 ise
sıfır
olacak
offset'inde
ilk asal sayı
var
c-g çağrısından
sonra
şimdi
okuma işlemini
yapacağım
ama okuma işlemini
formatsız
yapıyorum
int
x
asal sayı
tutacak
değişken
bu olsun
şimdi
ifs'nin
read'i
arkadaşlar
birinci parametre
char yıldız
tabi burada
char dediğime
bakmayın
stream'deki
karakter türü
yani
template parametresi
o yüzden
yine geçen dersimizi
hatırlayın
reinterpret
cast
char yıldız
address x
size of
int
önce okuma işlemini
yaptım
ve
yazayım şimdi
see out
arkadaşlar
and
inci
asal sayı
x
tabi dosyanın
doğru olduğunu
düşünüyoruz
sanıyorum
1 milyon asal sayı
vardı
evet
c'in
set işlemini
yapmamışım
c'in
n
kaçıncı asal sayı
777 bin
asal sayı
4 milyon
128 bin
mesela 1 milyon
anca asal sayı
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
15 milyonla
başlıyordu
1 milyon
16 milyon
bir dakika
aa
demek ki bu 1 milyon
değil
bakın bir yanlışlık var
çünkü bu asal sayı
değil
primes nokta
top
evet
şöyle bakalım
ama
mantığını anladınız
evet bir yanlışlık var
demek ki burada
bakalım şimdi
ha
ck çağrısı
yapmışım
doğru
evet
ya primes nokta
dot'ta bir hata var
çünkü doğru çalışmıyor
tekrar bakalım
kaçıncı asal sayı
evet
hata da yok
bir yerde bir yanlış yazdım
görüyorsanız
x
int x
ve orada bir hata yok
eninci asal sayı
x
read
reinterpret
as
char yıldız
size of
int
bu adresten
başlayarak
4 byte
sanıyorum dosyada bir program var
yoksa
yanlış çalışması için
bir neden yok
cd
n-1
çarpı
size of
int
c in
n
int yetmiyor
olabilir mi
yok canım
çünkü
1 milyon
asal sayı
15 milyon
küsür
orada öyle bir problem olmadığı açık
başka bir yerde bir hata olabilir
tekrar bakalım
evet
arkadaşlar bir dakika
n-1
çarpı size of
int
virgül
hatanın nerede olduğunu
bulacağım şimdi
ios'un
bagi
bir dakika
ya dosya
bozulmuş olabilir
bir şekilde
tamam doğru
evet
tamam doğru çalışıyor
f5
türle ilgili olabilir
nerede
tekrar
oraya gidelim
şimdi doğru çalışıyor
evet
main.chpp
1 milyon
çünkü biliyorum
15 milyon
küsür olması lazım
evet
yok
13 milyon
bakın yine yanlış çalışıyor
bir yerde bir hata var
dosyaya
bakalım
bir dakika
şöyle yapalım
adres
size of
int bir hata da yok
ilginç
bir dakika
n-1
şu dosyalara bir bakalım
ben de şimdi merak ettim
açıkçası
yanlış çalışmasına neden olacak
bir şey yok
open
containing
folder
crimes.dot
400 bin byte
burada da bir hata yok
bazen oluyor
bir küçük hata
gözden kaçabiliyor
şöyle yapalım
are
bir Brittany
reviewed
さい
tamam
böylece
çok
evet
lol
teşekkür
iedereen
çok
mention
bir
ổj
tới
keeper
baş
toen
ent
baş
LIVE
audible
Yes
Woche
Justice
ацион
employ
onto
baş
ting
aidir
İnt.
Bakarım ben sonra yani kodda bir hata yok çünkü ya da gözden kaçırdığımız çok basit bir şey var çünkü fonksiyon böyle çalışıyor.
Dosya konum göstericisini yeniden konumlandırdım.
11-13 dosyada bir hata yok.
Yoksa dosyayı binary modda mı açmadım diyorum o da binary modda açmışım.
İnt x indeksi aldık.
İlginç şey.
İndeksi aldık.
Bazen böyle bir körlük oluyor ya.
Çok basit bir şey görmüyorsunuz.
Int x
read
pardon önce
cg
ifs
Evet.
Şu orload'u
kullanıyorum.
Birinci parametresi
offset yani
n-1
çarpı
arkadaşlar
86 modunda
size of int
n-1
çarpı size of int
virgül
ay olsun
egi
ifs
read
cg
adres
x
ve
size of
int
Ben yanlış görmüyorum.
Ve
X
Enteresan.
Evet.
Bunu kapatalım.
Doğru
Doğru. Demin herhalde bir şey mi yazdım?
Adres operatörü
Doğru.
Bin
1 milyon
Bu yanlış.
Ben tahmin ediyorum.
Ne diyor?
1 milyon
Bin
Bir dakika.
Tamam.
Şöyle.
Burada
1 milyon tane asal sayı yok sanırım.
Ya da dosya bir şekilde
Bozuk.
Dosyaya tekrar bakalım
PrimeSort Data
Yani doğru çalışıyor ama
Dosyanın sonunda bir problem var.
Belki ben bir şekilde değiştireyim.
Şu dosya değil mi?
Arkadaşlar
Ya 100 bin asal sayı varmış.
1 milyon değil ki.
Bu kadar basit bir neden.
4 milyon değil.
400 bin
O sizin
Şimdi neden
Sıptığını anladınız mı?
Evet.
Tekrar bakalım.
400 bin
Tamam.
Bu doğru.
Şimdi ondan sonraki
Ver yanlış.
Bu çok olan bir şey.
Yani zaten arıyorsunuz ama
Testin kendisi yanlış.
Evet.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Ben onu 4 milyon gibi gördüm.
4 milyon olduğu için
Bir de
Bugün yazmadık ya
Geçen dersimizde yazdık.
4 milyon olduğu için
Ben de diyorum ki
1 milyon asal sayı var.
Oysa o 400 binmiş.
Dolayısıyla 100 bin asal sayı var.
Evet.
Dolayısıyla bir hata yok.
E bakın böyle yazmakla
Aslında
Doğrudan
Şu overloadu
Kullansaydım da
Olurdu.
Çünkü dosyanın
Başından itibaren
Konumlandırma yapıyorum.
Index gear
Arkadaşlar
Yine
Bu indekste
En eksi bir
Çarpı
Size of
Int
Ayosun
Bege
Evet.
Doğru çalışıyor.
Peki.
Şimdi birkaç tane soru
Artık konuyu sonlandıracağım.
Yeni konuya geçeceğim.
Arkadaşlar
Hem mülakatlarda
Sorulan sorular
Hem de üretimde
Çok
İhtiyaç
Duyulabiliyor.
Mesela bakınız
Bir vektörünüz var.
Çok klasik
Birkaç tane işlem.
Vektörümüz
Diyelim ki
Vektörün
Int açılımı
IVEC
Efendim
Generate
Algoritmin başlık dosyasını
Dahil edelim.
Vektörümüzde
Diyelim ki
100.000
Yani
Öğe olsun
Generate
Algoritmasını
Kullanalım.
IVEC
Begin
And
Ve
Utility
Başlık
Dosyasını
Dahil edelim.
IVEC
Begin
And
Iron
Sıfır
10.000
Sıfırla
Arasında
Sayılarla
Vektörümüzü
Doldurduk.
Şimdi
Yazma amaçlı
Bir dosyamız
Olsun.
Offstream
Sayılar
Nokta
Txt
Text
Dosyası
If
Değil
Offstream
Sıfırla
Keseceğim
CRR
Vata
Return
Bu sayıları
Text olarak
Dosyaya
Yazmak
İstiyorsunuz.
Bir kere de
Nasıl
Yazabiliriz?
Bir algoritmayla
Copy
Algoritmasını
Bulanabiliriz
Değil mi?
Hatırlayın
Copy
Ve
Ostream
İteratör
Hem şimdi
Istream
İteratörü de
Hazırlık
Olsun.
Ama
Copy
IVEC
Begin
And
Ostream
İteratörün
Int
Açılımı
Arkadaşlar
OFS
Örneğin
New Line
Eğer böyle
Yazarsam
Bu
Hatta
Burada
Açık bir
Dosyamız
Olsun
Uğraşmayalım
Out
Nokta
Txt
Örneğin
Copy
Algoritmasıyla
Ostream
İteratör
Sınıfını
Kullanarak
Dosyaya
Yazabilirim
Bakalım
Şimdi
Out
Nokta
Txt
Y
Gerçekten
De
Sayılarımız
Burada
Formansız
Olarak
Yazmak
İsteseydim
Yani
Bu sefer
Out
Nokta
Dot
Isimli
Bir
Dosyamız
Olsun
Binary
Motta
Açılmış
Olsun
Ve
Ben
Vektördeki
Tüm
Sayıları
Binary
Olarak
İteratör
Başlık
Dosyasını
Dahil
Ecektim
Ostream
İteratör
İçin
Binary
Olarak
Abdülkadir
Yazmak
İsteyelim
Bu
Durumda
Aslında
Neyi
Çağırmam
Gerekiyor
Write
Fonksiyonla
Ama
Write
Fonksiyonla
Birinci
Parametresi
Benden
Adresi
İkinci
Parametresi
İse
Kaç
Byte
Yazılacağı
Değerini
İstiyor
Zaten
Şimdi
Adres
Data
Fonksiyonu
Tarafından
Get edilebiliyor
Dolayısıyla
IVEC'in
Data
Fonksiyonuna
Çağırı
Ve
Şimdi
Stream
Size
Parametresine
Ne
Geçmem
Gerekir
Arkadaşlar
IVEC'in
Size
Şarpı
Of
Int
Tabi ki
IVEC'in
Datasının
Geri Dönüş
Değeri
Pointer
To
Int
Ama
Bizim
Buna
Çar
Yıldız
Vermemiz
Gerekiyor
O yüzden
Reinterpret
Cast
Char
Yıldız
IVEC'in
Datası
Böylece dosyaya
Binary olarak
Tek bir fonksiyonun
Char
Çağrısıyla
Asal sayıları
Yazdık
Şimdi
Tersini
Yapmamız
Gereksin
Yani
Elimizde
Out
Dot
Dosyası
Var
Ama
Binary olarak
Asal sayıları
Tutuyor
Bu sefer
Bunu
Vektora
Almak
İsteyeyim
Takip
Edebiliyor
Amıyoruz
Bu sefer
Ne yapacağım
Okuma
Amaçlı
Açacağım
If
Stream
Binary
Mod
Ips
Ios
Binary
Dosyanın ismi
Out
Nokta
Px
Şimdi
Dosyanın
Mesela
Şöyle olsun
Dosyada
Kaç tane
Asal sayı
Olduğunu
Bilmiyor
Olsam
İlave
Bir
Kütüphane
File
Sistem
Kütüphanesini
Kullanmasam
Aradaki
Kodları
Kontrol
Kodlarını
Geçiyorum
Dosya
Konum
Gösterişsini
Dosyanın
Sonunu
Alacağım
Tergiye
Fonksiyonuyla
Byte
Sayısını
Alacağım
Ama
Bakın
Size
T
Eşittir
Ips
Nin
Tergiye
Fonksiyonu
Bölü
Size
Of It
Çünkü
Tergiye
Bana
Byte
Sayısını
Verecek
Onu
Size
Of It
Değerine
Bölersem
Dosyada
Kaç tane
Asal sayı
Olduğu
Bilgisini
Elde
Edeceğim
Şimdi
Vektör
Nesnemi
Oluşturuyorum
Vektörün
İnt
Açılımı
Arkadaşlar
İvek
Size
Tane
Elemana
Sahip
Vektör
Şimdi
Tabi
Şu anda
Bütün
Değerler
Sıfır
Ama
Dosya
Konum
Gösterisi
Dosyanın
Sonuna
Çekildi
Bir
Hata
Da
Yok
Hata
Olmadığı
İçin
Yine
Ifs
C
G
Sıfır
Dosya
Konum
Gösterisini
Dosyanın
Başına
Çektim
Şimdi
Artık
Read
Fonksiyonunu
Çağırabilelim
Ifs
Read
Nereye
Reinterpret
Cast
Char
Yıldız
İvek'in
Datası
Virgül
Arkadaşlar
Size
Çarpı
Filt
Böylece
Vektörü
Bu
Şekilde
Almış
Oldum
Peki
Arkadaşlar
Şimdi
Bir
Neden
Bahsedelim
Aslında
Bir
Fonksiyon
Daha
Var
Bunu
Anlatayım
Anlatmayayım
Önemli
Olabilir
Arkadaşlar
Şimdi
Çok
Klasik
Bir
Soru
Ski
Out'un
Kontrol
Ettiği
O da
Bir
Stream
Değil
Mi
Kesinlikle
Yani
Normal
Bizim
Standart
Giriş
Akımı
Standart
Çıkış
Akımı
Standart
Hata
Akımı
Bunlar
Da
Stream
Şimdi
Şu Problem
Çok
Sık
Karşımıza
Çıkıyor
Biz
Standart
Alta
Bir
Şey
Yazmak
İstiyoruz
Fakat
Diyelim ki
Standart
Alta
Yazıyoruz
Fakat
Konsolda
Çıkmıyor
Birazda
Sistemin
Parametrelerine
Bağlı
Neden
Çıkmıyor
Çünkü
Standart
Alta
Bir
Stream
Ve
Onun
Da
Flash
Edilmesi
Gerekiyor
Yani
Siz
Standart
Alta
Flash
Etmediğiniz
Sürece
Bu
Bütün
Dosyalar
İçin
Geçerli
Fiilen
Device
Yazması
Gerçekleşmemiş
Oluyor
Dolayısıyla
Eğer
Böyle
Bir
Problemle
Karşılaşırsanız
Problemin
İlk
Nedeni
Olarak
Hemen
Neyi
Düşüneceksiniz
Ben
Yazdım
Ama
Sonuçta
Buffer'a
Yazdım
Buffer'ın
Flash
Edilmesi
Gerekiyor
Buffer'ın
Flash
Edilmesi
İçin
Arkadaşlar
Buffer'ın
Flash
Edilmesi
İçin
Ne
Yapmanız
Gerekiyor
Ya
Flash
Moksiyonu
Çağıracaksınız
Ya
Buffer
Dolacak
Bir
Önceki
Derste
Söylemiştim
Ama
Bu
Flash
İşleminin
Yapılması
İçin
Önemli
Bir
İvert
Daha
Var
Şu
Soruyu
Mürakatlarda
Sorduklarına
Bir
Kaç
Kez
Şahit
Oldum
Bence
Güzel
Bir
Soru
Diyor ki
Madem
Standart
Output
Buraya
Çok
Dikkatli
İzleyin
Madem
Standart
Output
Verilen
Yazıların
Gerçekten
Örneğin
Konsolda
Çıkması
İçin
Monitörde
Çıkması
İçin
Standart
Out
Flash
Edilmesi
Gerekiyor
Peki
Şöyle
Bir
Program
Yazıyorlar
Intx
Siyahat
Bir
Sayı
Giriniz
Ya da
Doğrudan
Yazalım
C
In
x
Arkadaşlar
Ve
Pardon
Şurada
Siyahat
Bir
Sayı
Giriniz
Var
Evet
Ve
C
x
Peki
Şimdi
Soruyu
Çok
Dikkatli
İzleyin
Hocam
Belki
Çok
Temel
Bir
Soru
Olabilir
Ama
Flash
Etmek
Nedir
Hemen
Cevap
Vereyim
Çok
Temel
Bir
Soru
Olması
Önemli
Değil
Arkadaşlar
Şimdi
Bu
Okuma
Yazma
İşlemleri
Bunları
C
Anlamıyorum
Hızlı
Olsun
Diye
Arkada
Bir
Bufferlama
Mekanizması
Var
Siz
Bir
Stream
Yazdığınız
Zaman
Fiziksel
Olarak
Devise
Yazmıyorsunuz
Bu
Buffer
Yazıyorsunuz
Dolayısıyla
Flash
İşlemi
Demek
Bu
Bufferdaki
Yani
Bellekteki
Byte'ların
Fiziksel
Olarak
Dosyaya
Yazılması
Demek
Dolayısıyla
Bu
İşlem
Yapılmadan
Yani
Dosyanın
Buffer'ındaki
Byte'lar
Fiziksel
Olarak
Dosyaya
Yazılması
İçin
Bu
Buffer'ın
Bufferdaki
O
Bellek
Alanındaki
Byte'ların
Dosya
Yazılması
İşlemine
Flash
Deniyor
Buffer'ı
Flash
Etmek
Ya da
Dosyayı
Flash
Etmek
Aynı
Anlamda
Kullanıyorlar
Bu
Flash
İşleminin
Yapılması
İçin
Bazı
Event'lerin
Gerçekleşmesi
Gerekiyor
Ne
Olabilir
Bu
Event'ler
Onları
Saydım
Tek
Biri
Buffer'ın
Dolması
Yani
Diyelim ki
Bu
Buffer
Byte
Siz
Byte'ı
Yazdığınız
Zaman
Buffer
Dolacak
Ve
Artık
Buffer'da
Yazacak
Yer
Olmadığı
İçin
Mecbur
Device'a
Aktarılacak
Böylece
Buffer'ı
Yine
Byte
Boş
Olarak
Kullanacaksınız
İkincisi
Buffer'ın
Dolmasını
Beklemeden
Sınıfın
Flash
Fonksiyonunu
Çağıracaksınız
Sınıfın
Flash
Fonksiyonu
Buffer'ı
Flash
Edecek
İşte
Bunu
Nerede
Anlatmıştım
Arkadaşlar
Bunu
Nerede
Anlatmıştım
İzleyin
Dedim ki
Şu
Antl
manipülatöründe
Bu da
Hem üretimde
Hem de
Bu mülakat tarafı
İçin önemli
Hep şöyle
Yazıyorlar ya
Cout
X
Antl
Bunun neden
Kötü olduğunu
Söylüyorlar
Şimdi
Bilmeyenler
Antl'nin
Ne olduğunu
Sanıyor
Bir derste
Antl'nin
Kodunu
Birlikte
Yazmıştık
Antl
Sanki
Stream'e
Newline
Karakteri
Vermek gibi
Oysa
Antl
Stream'e
Newline
Karakteri
Vermekle
Kalmıyor
Stream'i de
Ne yapıyor
Flash ediyor
Yani
Aslında
Antl
Şöyle bir
Fonksiyon
Geri dönüş
Değeri
O's
Stream
Referans
Tipik bir
O's
Stream
Manipülatörü
Efendim
Fonksiyon
İsmi
Antl
Aynı
Bu kodu
Yazmıştım
Belki
Atabileceksiniz
Parametre
Yine
Sput
O's
Stream
Referans
Böylece
Bu fonksiyona
Gelen
O's
Stream
Nesnesine
İlk
Önce
Bir
Newline
Veriyor
Ondan
Sonra
Bakın
Flash
Fonksiyonunu
Çağırıyor
Flash
Fonksiyonu
Puffer'dık
Karakterleri
Fiilen
Yazıyor
Device'a
Dolayısıyla
Siz
Newline
Vireyim
Diye
Sürekli
Antl
Yi
Çağırırsanız
Her
Antl
Kullanımında
Stream'i
Bir
Kez
Muhtemelen
Gereksiz
Olarak
Flash
Etmiş
Oluyorsunuz
İlave
Maliyet
Oluyor
Şimdi
Sorumuza
Geri
Dönecek
Olursak
Tekrar
Eski yere
Geri
Dönelim
Soru
Şu
Peki
Burada
Şöyle bir
Çağrı
Yapmamama
Rağmen
Çok
Dikkatli
Zey
Şöyle bir
Çağrı
Yapmamama
Rağmen
O
Zaman
Şöyle bir
Risk
Yok
Mu
Ya
Bir
Sayı
Giriniz
Yazısı
Standart
Output'un
Buffer'ı
Flash
Edilmediği
İçin
Ekranda
Çıkmazsa
O
Zaman
Programı
Kullanan
Kişi
Bir
Sayı
Girileceğini
Nereden
Anlayacak
Burayı
Anladınız
Mı
Arkadaşlar
Tekrar
Soruyorum
Eğer
Bu
Yazı
Çıkmazsa
Yani
Flash
İşlemi
Yapılmazsa
O
Zaman
Bu
Kod
Çalıştığında
Kişi
Bir
Sayı
Girmesi
Gerektiğini
Anlamaz
Ki
Dolayısıyla
Şunun
Sağlanması
Gerekiyor
Önce
Bu
Yazı
Çıkacak
Yani
Flash
İşlemi
Yapılacak
Ondan
Sonra
Giriş
İşlemi
Yapılacak
Espriyi
Anladınız
Mı
Evet
Peki
Bu
Neden
Garanti
Altında
Çünkü
Tay
Dediğimiz
Bir
İşlem
Var
Tay
İngilizce
Ne
Demek
Söyleyin
Tay
Bağlamak
Demek
Değil
Mi
Arkadaşlar
Tay
Şu
Demek
Bir
O
Stream
Bir
O
Stream
Ya
Da
I
Stream
Tay
Ettiğiniz
Zaman
Yani
Bağladığınız
Zaman
O
Nereyi
Bağladıysanız
Siz
Stream
Bir
Streamde
Giriş
İşlemi
Yaptığınızda
Onun
Bağlandığı
Stream
Otomatik
Olarak
Flash
Ediliyor
Yani
Aslında
Burada
Standart
Output'a
Bir
Sayı
Giriniz
Yazılmasının
Nedeni
Cout'un
Cine
Default
Olarak
Tay
Edilmiş
Olması
Buraya
Kadar
Anladık
Mı
Cout
Cine
Bağlandığı
İçin
Tay
Edildiği
İçin
Cinde
Bir
Okuma
Yaptığımda
İşleminden
Önce
C'in
Hangi
Stream'e
Tay edilmişse
O
Stream
Ne
İşlemine
Sokuluyor
Flash
İşlemine
Sokuluyor
Espreyi
Anladınız mı
Şimdi
Bunun
İçinde
Stream
Sınıf
Sınıflarının
I
İsimli
Bir
Fonksiyonu
Var
Arkadaşlar
Bakınız
Cout
I
Fonksiyonu
İki
Tane
Overload'a
Sahip
Get
Overload'u
Stream
Hangi
O
Stream'e
Bağlanmışsa
Tay edilmişse
O
Stream'in
Adresini
Veriyor
Mesela
Ben
Şöyle
Bir
Kod
Yazsam
Cout
C'nin
Bağlandığı
Belki burada
Bağlamak
Fiili
Türkçe'ye
Pek gitmiyor
Yani
Tay
İngilizcesi
Bağlandığı
Stream
Nesnesinin
Adresi
Bakın
Nesnesinin
Adresi
Eşittir
Cout
Tay
Daha önce
Biliyor muydunuz
Bu
Tay
Durumunu
Evet
Şimdi
Derdeyip
Çalıştırıyorum
Arkadaşlar
Evet
Bakın
C'nin
Şu anda
Bağlı değil
Tersini
Yazalım
Cout'un
Bağlandığı
Stream nesnesinin
C'nin
Demişim
Cout'un
Tayına
Bağlamışım
Ters
Yazmışım
C'nin
Tayı
Cout'un
C'nin
Tayı
Ben de
Döru
Niye
Null
Pointer'ı
Yazdım
Arkadaşlar
Bakın
C'nin
Bağlandığı
Stream
Nesnesinin
Adresi
E
D
Peki
Tahmin edin
Bu
Kimin
Adresi
C'nin
Default
Olarak
Cout'a
Bağlı
Olduğu
İçin
Bu
Aslında
Cout'un
Adresi
Takip
Edebiliyor
Muyuz
Yani
Ben
Bakın
İsterseniz
Deneyelim
Cout
Nesnesinin
Adresi
Adres
Cout
Şimdi daha iyi göreceksiniz
Bakın
Tay fonksiyonunun
Arkadaşlar
Geri dönüş
Değeriyle
Cout
Nesnesinin
Adresi
Aynı
Buradan
Niye
Anlıyoruz
Demek ki
C'nin
Cout'a
Tay edilmiş
Bu ne demek
C'nin de bir giriş
İşlemi
Yaptığımda
O
Hangi
O stream
Nesnesine
Tay edilmişse
O
O stream
Nesnesi
Flaş edilecek
Demek
Aslında
Biz
Bunu da
Değiştirebiliriz
Mesela
Ben
Bu sefer
Arkadaşlar
C'nin
High fonksiyonunu
Çağırsam
Adres
Cout
Desem
Buraya dikkat
İşte
Default
Durumu
Almış
Olurum
Yani
C'ni
Kime
Bağlamış
Oluyorum
Cout'a
Bağlamış
Oluyorum
Ama
Bu sadece
Standart
Giriş
Akımı
Standart
Çıkış
Akımı
İçin
Değil
Mesela
Diyelim ki
Elinizde
Arkadaşlar
İki
Tane
Dosya
Var
Birinin
If
Stream
Nesnesinin
İsmi
IPS
Off
Stream
Nesnesinin
İsmi
OPS
Şimdi
Siz
İPS
Bir okuma
Yaptığınızda
OPS
Y
Flaş
Edilsin
İstiyorsanız
İPS
Den her okuma
Yapıldığında
OPS
Flaş
Edilsin
İstiyorsanız
İPS
Y
Kime
Tay
Edeceksiniz
OPS
Y
Tay
Edeceksiniz
O zaman
Şöyle bir çağrı
Yapacaksınız
İPS
Tay
Adres
Arkadaşlar
OPS
Yani
O stream
Nesnesinin
Adresi
Tabi
Değişkenleri
Tanımlamadığım
İçin
Altını
Çiziyor
Eğer
Bir yere
Tay edilmişse
O
Bağlantıyı
Kopartmak
İstiyorsanız
Mesela
Ben
C'nin
Cout'a
Bağlı
Olmasını
İstemiyorum
O zaman
Null
Pointer
Geçiyorsunuz
Yani
C
In
Pay
Null
PTR
Böyle bir çağrı
Yaparsanız
C'nin
Bir yere
Bağlıysa
O
Bağlantıyı
Çıkartmış
Oluyorsunuz
Yalnız
Burada
Dikkat
Bağlama
Hedef
Her
Zaman
O
Stream
Bunu da
Şöyle
Görebilirsiniz
Bakınız
İstersiz
C'nin
Tayını
Çağırın
Arkadaşlar
Görüyorsunuz
Parametre
O
Stream
Pointer'ı
Aynı
Şekilde
O
Stream'i
Detay
Edebilirsiniz
O
Stream
Pay
Ama
Her
İkisinde
Parametre
O
Stream
Eğer
Bir
O
Stream'i
Stream'e
Tay
Ederseniz
Bu
Sefer
O
Stream
Üstünde
Çıkış
İşlemi
Yaptığınızda
Diğeri
Yine
Ne
Olacak
Flash
Edilecek
Yani
Her
Zaman
Flash
Edilen
Aslında
Type
Fonksiyonuna
Argüman
Olarak
Adresine
Geçtiğiniz
Stream
Orayı
Anladık
Mı
Evet
Mesela
Bakın
Şöyle
İşlemler
Düşünün
Şimdi
Sea
Out
Bugün
Hava
Çok
Soğuk
Örneğin
Siz
Bir
Dosyaya
Yazma
İşlemi
Yaptığınızda
Sea
Out'un
Da
Flash
Edilmesini
İstiyorsanız
Arkadaşlar
O
Zaman
Dosya
Diyelim ki
Ops
Pay
Adres
Sea
Out
Ya
Bir
Dosyadan
Okuma
Yaptığınızda
Sea
Out'un
Flash Edilmesini
İstiyorsanız
If
S
Tie
Adres
Sea
Out
Bir
Stream'in
Ya da
O stream'in
Hangi
Stream'e
Tie
Edildiğini
Öğrenmek
İstiyorsanız
Mesela
Bakın
Demin
Neden
Sıtır
Yazdım
Ben
Yanlış
Kıya
Yazdım
Ya
İzleyin
If
Sea
Out
Bakın
Tie
Null
Pointer
Sa
O
Daha
Neyi
Anlarım
Sea
Out
Herhangi bir
Stream'e
Bağlanmamış
Anlaşıldı
Değil mi
Sea
Out
Bağlı
Değil
Ama
Null
Pointer
Değilse
Ki
Şu anda
Null
Pointer
Olacak
As
Sea
Out
Hay
Adresi
İşte
Sea
Out
Hay
Funksiyonunun
Geri dönüşü
Diyelim
Evet
Peki
Arkadaşlar
Şimdi
Gelelim
iStream
İteratör
Sınıfına
Şimdiye
Kadar
Görmediğimiz
Ama
Çok
Önemli
Bir
Sınıf
Arkadaşlar
O
Stream
İteratör
Sınıfı
Ne
Yapıyor
Hatta
Kodumda
Yazmıştık
O
Stream
İteratör
Sınıfının
O
Stream
İteratör
Sınıfı
Aslında
Bir
Stream'e
Yazma
Yapmak
İçin
Kullanılıyor
Sınıfın
Nasıl
İmplemente
Edildiğini
Anlatmıştım
Mesela
Bakınız
O
Stream
İteratör
İter
O
Stream
İteratör
Int
Açılımda
İter
See
Out
Boşuk
Karakteri
Şimdi
İzleyin
Yıldız
İteratör
Eşittir
İçerik
Operatörünü
Kullandığım
Zaman
Atama
Operatörünü
Kullandığım
Zaman
Ne
Yapıyordu
İşte
Bu
Stream'e
Yazma
İşlemine
Dönüştürüyor
Şimdi
Standart
Output'a
Yazacak
Ve
Bir
Boşluk
Karakteri
Yazacak
Eğer
Ben
Aynı
İşlemi
Tekrar
Yaparsam
Bir
Yazma
İşlemi
Daha
Yapacak
Eğer
Ben
Artı
Operatörünü
Kullanırsam
Etkisiz
Yani
Hiçbir
Etkiye
Sahip
Olmayacak
Yine
Örneğin
Peki
Bunun
Faydası
Ne
Bu
Şekilde
Kullanmanızda
Hiçbir
Engel
Yok
Ama
Faydası
Algoritmalarla
Kullanabilmeniz
İşte
Demin
Örneğini
Verdim
Mesela
Hadi
Bir
Örnek
Daha
Bir
Önceki
Örneğe
Geri
Dönelim
Şu
Vektör
Örneğine
Neyse
İnden
Yazalım
Basit
Vektör
Bek
Diyelim ki
Bu
Vektör
Üstünde
Herhangi
Bir Algoritmaya
Yazma
İşlemi
Yapacağım
Bunları
Daha Önce
Anlattım
Ama
Konunun
Anlaşılması
İçin
Önce
O
String
Taratör
Sınıfın
Tekrarını
Yapalım
Yeter
Mesela
Bakınız
Kopi
Algoritması
Algoritmin
Başlık
Dosyası
Dahil
Edilmiş
Bir
Kaç
Tane
Örneğ
Kopi
Vektik
Vekent
Ostream
Yeteratörün
Int açılımı
Arkadaşlar
Steerout
Ve
Seperatör
Olarak
Oluçlu
Karakteri
Nereye
Yazacak
Construct
Ederken
Construct'lara
Hangi
Ostream
Nesnesini
Geçerseniz
Oraya
Yazacak
Ve
Eğer
İkinci
Parametreye
Argüman
Geçmezseniz
Boşluk
Karakteri
Olmayacak
Yani
Null
String'i
Seperatör
Olarak
Kullanacak
Şimdi
Hepsi
Yan Yanına
Yazacak
Ama
Şimdi
İkinci
Parametreye
Seperatör
Olarak
Boşluk
Verirsem
Arada
Birer
Karakter
Boşluk
Olacak
Eğer
Burada
New
Line
Verseydim
Seperatör
Olarak
Her
Birobeyi
Yazdıktan
Sonra
Seperatörü
Stream'e
Verecekti
Ama
Şimdi
Bu
Sadece
Standart
Output'a
Yazmak
İçin
Değil
Gördüğünüz
Gibi
Ismi
Output'a
Offstream'e
Bir
Output'a
Yani
Örneğin
Ismi
Output'a
TX'e
Olan
Bir
Dosya
Olsaydı
Ve
Bu
Dosyayı
Kontrol
Eden
Output'a
Şimdi de
Yazma
İşlemini
Nereye
Yapacaktı
Output'a
Yani
Dosyaya
Yazacaktı
Şimdi
Bakın
Output'a
TX'e
Bakın
Gördüğünüz
Gibi
Yazmış
Ama
Bu
Bütün
Yazma
Algoritmaları
İçin
Geçerli
Mesela
Ben
Copy
Yerini
If'i
Yazsaydım
Hedef
İteratör
Olarak
O stream
İteratörün
Int
Açılımı
Bunu
Verseydim
Ve
Efendim
Predicate
Parametri
Olarak
Arkadaşlar
Int
X
Lambda
İfadesi
Kullansaydım
Efendim
Return
X
Mod 2
Eşit
Sıfır
Şimdi
Bu sefer
Dosyaya
İkiye
Tam
Bölünenleri
Yazacaktı
Takip edebiliyor muyuz
Evet
Ya da şuna
Bakın
Gayet güzel bir örnek
Generate
Algoritması
Şimdi
Generate
Algoritmasında
Bakın
Forward
İteratör
Ve
Bir
Konteynerı
Bununla
Dolduruyor
Değil mi
Ama
Generate
N
Algoritmasına
Bakın
Generate
N'de
İse
Konksiyonun
Birinci
Parametresi
Yazılacak
Hedef
Aslında
Diyelim ki
Elimde
Bir
Vektör
Olsaydı
Generate
N'i
Şöyle
Kullanabilirdim
Değil mi
Vek
Begin
Arkadaşlar
Ve
Sonra
Diğer
Parametreler
O
Zaman
Yazma
Algoritmaları
Benden
Her
Zaman
Yazma
Reğincinin
Başlangıcını
İstiyor
O
Zaman
Generate
N'i
Bakın
Şimdi
Ben
O
Stream
İteratörün
Int
Açılımı
Arkadaşlar
Efendim
See
Out
Ve
New
Line
Argümanını
Versem
Takip
Edebiliyor
Musunuz
Evet
Generate
N'in
İkinci
Parametresine
Arkadaşlar
Bakın
Generate
N
Şöyle
Göstereyim
İkinci
Parametresine
Şurada
Gösterelim
Parametrelerini
De
Şaşırmayalım
Sizde
Şaşırmayın
Takip
Generate
Şundan
Bahsediyor
İkinci
Parametresi
Kaç
Tane
Öğe
Yazılacağ
Üçüncü
Parametresi
Generatör
O Zaman
Bakın
Şimdi
Tane
Ve
Airend
Ne
Yapacak
Bu
Durumda
Jeneratörü
Kullanarak
Arkadaşlar
Bu
Şurada
Kime
Parantez
Kapanmamış
Bu
Jeneratörü
Kullanarak
Post
Reimiteratörle
O da
C6'a
Bağlanmış
Tane
Tam
Sayı
Yazacak
Airend'in
Döngünler
Turunda
Airend'in
Fonksiyon
Çağrı
Operatörünü
Çağıracak
Dolayısıyla
Biz
Ekranda
Arasında
Rastgele
Tane
Sayı
Gördük
Eğer
Şöyle
Yazsaydım
Bu
Sayılar
Yan
Yana
Yazacaktı
Birer
Boşlukta
Eğer
Şöyle
Yazsaydım
İkinci
Parametreye
Bunu
Geçseydim
Ki
Bu da
Default
Argüman
Zaten
Bunları
Bitişik
Yazacaktı
Takip
Edebildik
Mi
Zaten
Bu
Default
Argüman
O
String
İteratör
Sınıfı
Son derece
Önemli
Ya da
Bakın
Şimdi
Başka
Bir
Örnek
O
String
İteratörün
Açılımı
Cout
Airend
Yerine
Random
Name
O zaman
Ne yapacak
Standart
Alkut
Tane
Rastgele
İsim
Yazacak
Görüyorsunuz
Nasrullah
Tayfun
Süleyman
Abdülmuttal
Tekrar
Çalıştırıyorum
Kazım
Dayana
Mahir
Cemal
Tekrar
Çalıştırıyorum
Nurullah
Tuncer
Ya da
Burada
Jeneratör
Olarak
Random
Sörneyimi
Kullansaydım
Bu
Jeneratörde
Rastgele
Bir
Soy
İsim
Oluşturuyordu
Görüyorsunuz
Bostaj
Karaduman
Erdemiz
Vesaire
Ya da
Kendi
Jeneratörüm
İçin
Bir
Lambda
İfadesi
Kullansaydım
Bunlara
Benzer
Örnekler
Yaptık
Arkadaşlar
Bunun da
Return
İfadesi
İzleyen
Random
Name
Plus
Bir
Boşluk
Plus
Random
Sörneyimi
Olsaydı
Ve
Burada
Da
New
Line
Kullansaydım
Standart
Output
Tane
İsim
Soy
Yazacaktı
Her
Satıra
Şimdi
O
String
Teratör
Sınıfı
Son Derece
Önemli
Evet
Şurada
Random
Name
Artı
Random
Sörneyim
Fonsiyon çağrı
Önce
Örneği
Tamamlayalım
Evet
Bakın
Nurullah
Tepecik
Bergeri
Emine
Kılıçdar
Predicate
Parametrisi
Fank
Parametrisinin
Bir
Altbaşlığı
Gibimi
Tamamen
Tamamlayamadım
Ama
Şöyle
Ben
Sorunuzu
Tahmin
Ediyorum
Şimdi
Predicate
Demek
Buğul döndüren
Polibul
Demek
Predicate
Geri dönüş
Değeri
Buğul olan
Polibul
Eğer
Bunun
Böyle bir
Polibul'ın
Tek bir
Parametrisi
Varsa
Onu
Vurgulamak
İçin
Unary
Diye de
Telahfiz
Unary
Predicate
Eğer
İki
Parametreyle
Buğul döndüren
Bir
Polibul'sa
Ona
Binary
Predicate
Diyoruz
Takip
Takip edebiliyor muyuz
Eğer
Colibul
Bir
Predicate
Değilse
Ama
Predicate
Olmayan
Özel
Bir
Fonksiyonsa
Onu
Vurgulamak
İçin
Predicate
Terimini
Kullanmak
Yerine
Function
Terimini
Kullanıyoruz
Yani
Örneğin
Unary
Function
Ve
Binary
Function
Gibi
Devam
Edelim
Tamamlayalım
Resul'ün
Sorusunun
Cevabını
Bazı
Algoritmalar
Bizden
Predicate
İstiyor
Yani
Geri
Dönüş
Değeri
Buğul
Olan
Fonksiyon
İstiyor
Örneğin
Sonu
İple
Biten
Algoritmalar
Antif
Apif
Replace
Gibi
Bazı
Algoritmalar
Binary
Predicate
İstiyor
Mesela
Sort
Algoritması
Karşılaştırma
İşlemini
Yapacak
Binary
Predicate
İstiyor
Bizden
Ama
Bazı
Fonksiyonlarda
İşte
Bizim
Son
Örneğimizdeki
Arkadaşlar
Generate
End
Olduğu
Gibi
Bizden
İstediği
Predicate
Aslında
Diyorum
Bizden
İstediği
Callable
Aslında
Parametresiz
Olarak
Çağrılacak
Fakat
Geri
Dönüş
Değeri
Üretilen
Bir
Değer
Olacak
Ki
Algoritma
Döngüsel
Bir
Yapıda
Döngünler
Durumda
O
Generator'ı
Çağıracak
İşte
Böyle
Fonksiyonlara
Buradaki
Random
Name
Ya da
Random
Surname
Gibi
Geri
Dönüş
Değeri
Üretilen
Değer
Olan
Callable
İçin
Kullanılan
Terim
De
Generator
Bilmiyorum
Sorunuza
Doğru
Anlamış
Mıyım
Doğru
Cevap
Verebildim
Şimdi
Gelelim
Istream
Literatör
Sınıfına
Arkadaşlar
Istream
Literatör
Sınıfı
Sizi
Bir
Hayli
Şaşırtmaya
Aday
Istream
Literatör
Sınıfı
Bu
Sefer
Okuma
Renci
Olarak
Kullanılıyor
Buraya
Dikkat
Mesela
Bakınız
Çok
Dikkatli
İseyin
O
Kadar
Çok
Yerde
Kullanabilirsiniz
Ki
Eğer
Bstream
Okuma
Yapacaksanız
Yani
Okuma
İşlemi
Yapan
Bir
Algoritmada
Input
Olarak
Kullanacaksanız
Ama
Input
Olarak
Kullandığınızda
Örneğin
Bir
Arkadaşlar
Stream
Olacaksa
Bu
Herhangi bir
Istream
Olabilir
Mesela
If
Stream
Olabilir
Arkadaşlar
Istring
Stream
Olabilir
Istream
Tek
Yapmanız
Gereken
Range
Oluşturmak
İçin
Buraya
Dikkat
Range
Başlangıç
İteratörü
Olarak
Bakın
Istream
İteratör
Bu
Bir
Tabiki
Sınıf
Şablonu
Yine
Template
Argümanı
Olarak
O
Streamden
Gelecek
Öğelerin
String
Olarak
Alınmasını
İstiyorsanız
String
Açılımı
Int
Olarak
Alınmasını
İstiyorsanız
Int
Açılımı
Double
Olarak
Alınmasını
İstiyorsanız
Double
Açılımını
Kullan
Construct
Argüman
Olarak
Istream
Nesnesini
Vereceksiniz
Böylece
Bu
İfade
Range
Begin
İteratörü
Olarak
Ele
Alınacak
Ama
Bir de
Bizim
End
İteratörüne
İhtiyacımız
Var
Değil mi
End
İteratörü
İçinde
Istream
İteratörün
Aynı
Türden
Default
Konstrukt
Edilmiş
Bir
İfade
Geçeceksiniz
Yani
Şöyle
Istream
İteratör
Herkes dikkat
Neyse
Istream
İteratör
Int
Ve
Temporary
Object
Takip
Edebiliyor
Muyuz
Arkadaşlar
Mesela
Bakın
Örnekler
Yapalım
Basit
Örnekler
Yapalım
Mesela
Istream
Stream
Estream
Başlık
Dosyasını
Ekleyelim
Örneklerin
Hepsi
Bence
Çok
Önemli
Istream
Stream
ISS
Delim ki
Bu
Streamde
Şu
Yazılar
Var
Arkadaşlar
Efendim
Takip
Edebiliyor
Müyüz
Sonuçta
Bu
Bir
Stream
Değil
Mi
Bu
Stream
Bir
Algoritmada
Input
Olarak
Kullanabilir
Miyim
Cevap
Evet
Bakın
İsterseniz
İzleyin
Tek
Yapmam
Gereken
Aslında
Istream
İteratörün
Önce
Algoritmadan
Bağımsız
Olarak
Kullanayım
Int
Açılımı
Diyelim ki
İter
Ama
Constructor'ına
Argüman
Olarak
Stream
Nesnesine
Verdi
Arkadaşlar
Şimdi
Bakın
Intix
Eşittir
Yıldız
İter
Böylece
Yıldız
İter
İşlemi
Bunu
Neye
Dönüştürecek
Bu
Streamden
Bir
Okuma
İşlemi
Yapmaya
Formatlı
Okuma
İşlemi
Yapmaya
Bakın
X'in
Değerini
Yazdırıyorum
X'in
Değeri
Ne
Olacak
Arkadaşlar
Şimdi
Ama
Bunu
Tabi
Bu
Şekilde
Kullanmak
Yerine
Genel
Olarak
Ne
Yapıyoruz
Algoritmalarda
Input
Range
Olarak
Kullanıyoruz
Mesela
Bakınız
İzleyin
Estring
Stream
E
SS
Herhangi
Bir
Algoritma
Alalım
Mesela
Hangi
Algoritma
Arkadaşlar
Accumulate
Nümerik
Başlık
Dosyasında
Accumulate
Normalde
Bakınız
Accumulate'in
Parametreleri
İteratör
Değil
Mi
Range
İteratörleri
Şimdi
Eğer
Ben
Bir
Vektörden
Okuma
Yapsaydım
Örneğin
Ivec
Bekin
Ent
Geçecektim
Ama
Şimdi
Ne
Geçiyorum
Istream
İteratörü
Int
Açılımı
Arkadaşlar
ISS
Ve
İkinci
Parametresine
Istream
İteratörün
Int
Açılımı
Geçici
Nesne
Ve biliyorsunuz
Accumulate
Algoritmasını
Anlatmıştım
Üçüncü
Parametresi
Hangi
Değere
Toplamayı
Yapacak
Sıfır
Accumulate'in
Geri Dönüşleri
Bu
Accumulate
Eden
Değer
Dolayısıyla
C
Out
Aslında
Neyin
Toplamı
Buradaki
Sayıların
Toplamı
Şimdi
Örneği
Biraz Daha
Değiştirelim
Bakın
Espriye
Yine
Accumulate'i
Kullanıyorum
Fakat
Bu
Sefer
Istream
İteratörün
String
Açılımı
Estream
İteratörün
String
Açılımı
Ve
Başlangıç
Değeri
Olarak
String
Default
Konstrakt
Edilmiş
Bir
String
Vereyim
Bu
Sefer
Bunları
Yazı
Olarak
Toplayacak
Değil mi
Görüyor
Musunuz
Aslında
Şu
Yazıları
Topladı
Ama
Sadece
Arkadaşlar
Ne için
Geçerli
Değil
Sadece
Islinc
Stream
İçin
Geçerli
Değil
Şimdi
Dosyaya
Bakın
Mesela
Herhangi
Bir
Dosyanız
Olsun
Bakın
Burada
Alt nokta
TXT
Var
Diyelim
Diyelim ki
Ben
Bu
Dosyadaki
Whitespace
Karakterlerle
Ayrılmış
Tam
Sayıları
Bir
Algoritmada
Kullanacağım
Mesela
Copy
Algoritması
Bakın
Ne
Kadar
Kolay
Olduğunu
Göreceksiniz
Önce
Dosyayı
Oluşturuyorum
Oda
Istream
Nesnesi
If
Stream
S
Alt nokta
TXT
Bakın
Şimdi
Vektörün
Range
Constructor
Var
Değil
Mi
O
Zaman
Istream
İteratör
Sınıfıyla
Da
Stream
Üstünde
Bir
Range
Oluşturabilirim
Değil
Mi
O
Zaman
Tek
Yapmam
Gereken
Diyelim ki
Vektörün
Int
Açılımı
Türünden
IVEC
Arkadaşlar
Range
Constructor
Na
Istream
İteratörün
Int
Açılımı
IFS
İkinci
Parametreye
De
Default
Construct
Edilmiş
Bir
Istream
İteratör
Nesnesi
Veriyorum
Istream
İteratör
Int
Açılımı
Geç
Nesne
Takip
Ede
Bildik
İsterseniz
Bakın
Şimdi
Bizim
C
Print
Fonksiyonuyla
Vektörümüzü
Yazdıralım
Gerçekten
Dosyadan
Alındığını
Göreceksiniz
Şimdi
Burada
Neler
Yapabiliriz
Yavaş
Çarş
Gidelim
Bir
Range
End
Olarak
Eğer
Bir
Algoritmaya
Çare
Yapacaksanız
Template
Argument
Dedaction'dan
Faydalanmak
İçin
Default
Construct
Edilmiş
Bir
Nesneyi
Şöyle
De
Geçebilirsiniz
İzleyin
Küme
Parantezi
Çok
Tipik
Bir
Yedi
Aslında
Burada
Bu
Fonksiyon
Bir
Şablonu
Olduğu
İçin
Derleyici
Burada
İkinci
Parametrenin
Birinci
Parametreye
Gönderilen
Argümanın
Türünden
Olduğunu
Anlıyor
Yani
Yine
Aynı
Şekilde
Çalışacak
Hatta
Bakın
Şimdi
Eğlenceli
Bir
Şey
Yapalım
Ve
Stream
Literatör
Sınıfı
Öğrenci
O
Kadar
Güzel
Şeyler
Yapabilirsiniz
Ki
Bakın
Şimdi
Ben
Şu
Espriyi
Çok
Yapıyorum
Bir
Tane
Programlama
Bir
Mülakatta
Giriyorsunuz
Size
Şöyle
Bir
Soru
Soruyorlar
Standart
Input
Kullanıcı
İstediği
Kadar
Tam
Sayı
Girecek
Diyelim ki
Bu
Tam
Sayıların
Toplamını
Ekrana
Yazdıracaksınız
Şimdi
Sizde
Şov
Yapmak
İçin
Bunu
One
Liner
Olarak
Yazmak
İstiyorsunuz
Ya
Mümkün
En kısa
Kodu
Yazmak
İstiyorsunuz
Soru
Scene'de
Bir
Istream
Nesnesi
Değil mi?
Kesinlikle
O zaman
Ben
Istream
İteratörün
Bir dakika
Istream
İteratörün
Takip
Takip edin
Int
Açılımı
Scene
İkinci
Parametreye
Default
Construct
Edilmiş
Istream
İteratörün
Esnesini
Versem
Üçüncü
Parametreye
Ben de
Sıfır
Değerini
Geçsem
Ve
Accumulate
Fonksiyonunu
Bu argümanlarla
Çağırsam
Ve
Accumulate'in
Geri dönüş
Değerini
Standart
Altında
Yazdırsam
Arkadaşlar
One
Liner
Olarak
Standart
İmputtan
Gelen
Sayıların
Toplamını
Hesatlayan
Bir kod
Yazmış
Olurum
One Liner
Derken
Şu
Using
Bildirimini
Kullanmak
Zorunda
Değil
Hadi
O zaman
Gerçekten
One Liner
Yapalım
Stude
Cout
Accumulate
Ya da
ADL
Stude
Istream
C
Bakın
Tek bir kod
Tek bir deyim
Değil mi
One Liner
Çalıştırıyorum
Takip edin diye
Küçük sayılar
Gireceğim
Ama tabi
Girişi
Standart
İmputtan
Yaptığım
İçin
Arkadaşlar
Ctrl
Z
Enter
Gördüğünüz gibi
Hatta
Bakın
Başka bir örnek
Bu sefer
Max
Element'i
Çağırayım
Aynı
Range'i
Vereyim
Max
Element
Ama
İteratör
Döndürüyor
Değil mi
Ama Max
Element'in
Geri döndürdüğü
İteratörü
Bir referans
Edy
Bu
One Liner'da
Ne yapacak
Necati'nin
One Liner'ları
Bu sefer
Standart
Input'tan
Girilen
Tam sayılardan
En büyüğünü
Ekrana
Yazdıracak
İsterseniz
Deneyelim
Arkadaşlar
Yıldız
Şurası
Fazla
Oldu
Evet
Stude
C
Is
Limiteratör
Int
E
Sıfır
Fazla
Oldu
Evet
Bu
Kadar
Bakın
Aslında
Is
Stream
İteratörün
Bazen
Kodlarda
Böyle
Görürsünüz
Is
Stream
İteratör
Ben
Gereksiz
Görüyorum
It
Şimdi
Buradaki
Is
Stream
İteratör
Arkadaşlar
Buradaki
Is
Stream
İteratör
Default
Construct
Edilmiş
Bir
Is
İteratör
Nesnesi
Değil mi
Ozan
Fonksiyonun
Bu
Parimetresine
İsimlendirilmiş
Bir
Default
Construct
Edilmiş
Is
Stream
İteratör
Nesnesi
Geçmem
Burada
Herhangi
Bir
Şekilde
Engel
Yok
Ama
Daha
Güzelini
Yapacağız
Şimdi
Şaşıracaksınız
Open
Contain prejudi
Benim
Asal
Sayı
Text
Dosyalarım
Vardı
Bakın
Primes
1 Milyon
Nokta
TXT
Şimdi
Bu
Boşluklarla
Ayrılmış
1 Milyon
Tane
Asal
Sayı
Var
Hatta
Buraya
Açmışım
Bakın
Peki
Bunu
Bir
Konteynöre
alabilir miyim? Aynı şekilde
evet. Bakın. İzleyin.
Arkadaşlar.
Ifstream
espiraya bakışın.
ifs
primes
1.123
1.123.txt
Yine dosyanın açılıp
açılmadığını kontrol edin.
If değil ifs
see out
açılamadı.
Return 1. Şimdi bakın.
Range Constructor'ı kullanıyorum.
Vektörün
int açılımı türünden
if
ifstream iteratörün
int açılımı
ifs
ve
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
ve şimdi bakın.
Gerçekten
benim vektörümde
Alihan
kaç tane tam sayı olacak?
Eğer primes
1.123.txt'de
1.123.txt'e
asal sayı varsa
o zaman
vektöre de
bunları almış olacağım.
isterseniz kontrol edelim.
see out
size
eşittir
ibeck'in
size
ve hatta
şöyle göstermek için
for
const
int
i
ibeck
tabi sonuna kadar yazdırmayacağım.
see out
i
ama
şurada
tabi durdurmazsak
onu göremeyiz.
sıkı saçma olur.
get car
evet
kapasitesini de
düzenleyebiliriz.
bakın
size
1.000.000
ve sayılar
hatta
şöyle bir şey yapalım mı
1.000.000
ilk 1.000.000
asal sayının
toplamını
bulmak isteseydik
süreye kadar
kod aynı olacaktı.
burada da
accumulate
algoritması
ibeck
begin
end
arkadaşlar
buraya dikkat
sıfır
long long
aşma olmasın diye
değer aldım.
fonksonun geri dönüş
değerde de
long long
olacak.
bakalım
ilk 1.000.000
asal sayının
toplamını
soruyorlar.
evet
ister inanın
ister inanmayın
arkadaşlar
şöyle bakalım
nokta
ya da
şöyle yapalım
alt nokta
txt yazdırayım
ilk 1.000.000
asal sayının
toplamı
arkadaşlar
ilk 1.000.000.000
asal sayının
toplamı
kaçmış
şöyle
üçer üçer
ayıralım
nokta
evet
şurası
milyon
burası
milyar
trilyon
7 trilyon
472.000.000.000
966.000.000
967.000.000
499.000.000
ilk
1.000.000
asal sayıyı
toplarsak
bu değeri
elde edecekmişiz.
anlaşıldı mı?
evet
buradan şunu
görüyorsunuz
ister bir
iString
stream olsun
arkadaşlar
ister bir
efendim
if stream
olsun
yeter ki
iStream
olsun
orada
iStream
iteratör
sınıfını
kullanarak
range
gereken
her yerde
onu
kullanabilirim
mesela
bakınız
izleyin
şu bir
range
değil mi?
evet
bu
range
şimdi ben
bütün asal sayıları
üstünde
bazı işlemleri
yapmak için
işte
toplam gibi
max gibi
max'ı çağırmam
max element'i çağırmam
bana bir faydası olmayacak
çünkü zaten
en sonuncusu
en büyük
ama diyelim ki
ilk 1 milyon
asal sayı içinde
çok özel bir işlem
yapacağız
işte
basamakları
toplamı
hatta bunu bir soru olarak
yapalım
bir dahaki derste
ilk 1 milyon
asal sayıda
basamakları
toplamı
verilen sayı olan
ilk asal sayıyı
bulunuz
hatta bunu
yazalım isterseniz
öyle bitirelim
evet
izleyin
şimdi
bunun için
önce
basitleştirmek için
bir tane
predikat olarak
kullanılacak
lambda
ifadesi
alalım
c
alt
toplam değerini
girin
bir tane
ayıttır
mak başkalar
int x
return
sum digit
diye bir fonksiyon. Hadi o fonksiyonu da buraya
yazalım.
Onu da lambda ifadesi yapalım.
int
sum digit
int x
özür dilerim. Lambda yapalım demiştim.
Evet.
Bu bitsin. Ben de bitireceğim.
int x
int sum
eşit sıfır
while
x
sum
artı eşit
x modun
x
bölü eşit on.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet. Arkadaşlar
return sum.
Şimdi buradan buraya
lambda ifadesi.
Buna isim verelim.
auto
digit sum
eşittir.
f redde de
digit sum'ı
arkadaşlar ve sum'ı
capture edelim.
ve bizim bu lambda ifademizde
return
digit sum
x
eşit eşit
sum.
şimdi artık bunu
ekbreli
predikat olarak kullanıp
herhangi bir algoritmayı
çağırabilirim değil mi?
mesela
find if
arkadaşlar
stream iteratör
int açılımı
ifs
beful
constractor
ve
sum
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
sum diyorum özür dilerim.
f
pred
auto
iter
eşittir
eşittir.
if
iter
eşit değilse
stream iteratörün
int açılımı
birçin esne
bu da
alt konumu
değil miydi?
see out
yıldız iter
evet
see out
bulundu
yıldız iter
as
see out
bulunamadı
biraz daha hızlı yazdık
vakitte de açtım
sizde 3-4 dakika
kusura bakmayın
ama bir deneyelim
evet
çalıştıralım
mesela
37 toplamını
veren
ilk asas sayı
ne güzel değil mi?
89'muş
bakın
basamakları toplamı
37 olan
ilk asal sayı
buymuş
biraz
arttıralım
basamakları toplamı
acaba
41 olan
varmış
bu
basamakları toplamı
99 olan
ilk sayı
bulunamadı
basamakları toplamı
77 olan
ilk 1 milyon
asal sayı
da yok
basamakları toplamı
55 olan
ilk asal sayı
2 milyon
bin
deneyelim mi?
5 tane
8 daha
2 daha
bugünkü dersimizde
nihayet
sizi tuttum ama
burada sona eriyor
bir dahaki hafta
görüşmek üzere
herkese
şimdiden
iyi bir
hafta sonu
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
abone ol